Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. His deepest need was that people should like him. An admirable trait that, in a spaniel or a whore, not, I think, in a prime minister. And we've done him a favour too, if he did but know it. He was in the trap and screaming from the moment he took office. We've simply put the poor bastard out of his agony. After life's fitful fever, he sleeps well. So let's not involve ourselves in any squeamishness, all right? Because this is just the start.
感谢收听《历史余音》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告内容、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。他内心最深处的渴望是得到所有人的喜爱。这在长毛猎犬或妓女身上或许是个令人赞赏的特质，但在我看来，对首相而言则不然。而且，如果他自己心知肚明的话，我们其实也算帮了他一个大忙。从他上任的那一刻起，他就落入了陷阱，并在那里尖叫。我们不过是帮这个可怜的混蛋解脱了痛苦。在经历人生的颠簸狂热之后，他终于安眠了。所以，让我们不要表现得那么矫情，好吗？因为这仅仅是个开始。
That, Dominic Sandbrook, was Francis Urquhart, Chief Whip. That was chilling. That was absolutely chilling. As played by Ian Richardson in the BBC 1990 drama House of Cards, which was screened at exactly the moment that Mrs Thatcher was being defenestrated by the Tory party. And the reason that I've used that as an introduction, and the reason that we're doing this special Restless History episode is because the Tory party is engaged, it seems, in another process of regicide. So we are recording this at quarter past nine on Monday, the 6th of June, and 15 minutes ago, the results of a vote of confidence on the Prime Minister Boris Johnson were announced. And he won it, but kind of not brilliantly.
多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook），刚才那是党鞭弗朗西斯·厄克特（Francis Urquhart）。那段话太让人不寒而栗了。绝对令人毛骨悚然。由伊恩·理查森（Ian Richardson）在BBC 1990年播出的电视剧《纸牌屋》（House of Cards）中饰演，该剧播出之时，正是撒切尔夫人被保守党赶下台的那个精确时刻。我之所以用它作为开场，我们之所以要做这期特别的《历史余音》节目，是因为保守党似乎又在进行一场弑君行动。所以我们是在6月6日星期一晚上九点一刻进行录制的，就在15分钟前，关于首相鲍里斯·约翰逊的不信任投票结果公布了。他赢了，但赢得实在不算太好。
Yeah, 2-1-1. He won 2-1-1, 211 votes, and 148 Tory MPs said they had no confidence in him. So that's 41% of his parliamentary party said they didn't have confidence in him. And for context, that's the worst performance, I think, by a conservative leader in a confidence vote in my lifetime. So it's worse, crucially, than Theresa May, his predecessor in 2019, because she won 200 votes with 117 against. So the percentages were in her favor relative to boris johnson so he is you know with with four out of ten tory mps lacking confidence in him he is shall we say at the very least grievously wounded well dominic i i have a metaphor here drawn from the world of
对，211票。他赢了211票，有148名保守党议员表示对他不信任。所以这意味着他41%的党内议员表示对不信任他。从背景来看，我认为这是在我有生之年，保守党领袖在信任投票中表现最差的一次。至关重要的是，这比他的前任特雷莎·梅在2019年的表现还要糟糕，因为当时她赢了200票，反对票是117票。所以相对鲍里斯·约翰逊而言，支持率对她更有利，因此，鉴于有十分之四的保守党议员对失去信心，他可以说是、退一步讲至少也是遭受了重创。好吧，多米尼克，我这里有一个比喻，取材于自然
natural history which i know you're a big fan of big fan so komodo dragons the world's largest kind the world's largest lizard um they have incredibly toxic um teeth and breath and tongues and all they have to do is give uh you know a passing mammal a deer or whatever a little nip and all the bacteria get to work and then the komodo just kind of follows the deer the deer slowly gets more and more sick and it collapses, and then the Komodo dragon eats it. Who's the Komodo dragon? Jeremy Hunt, in this analogy. I suppose the Tory party, I guess. Yes. So I think this result does justify perhaps looking at the history of prime ministerial downfalls. Definitely. Definitely. And you, I've been in the library all day looking at the murder of Caesars and things,
历史界——我知道你是这方面的超级粉丝。超级粉丝。所以科莫多巨蜥，世界上最大的种类，世界上最大的蜥蜴，嗯，它们有着极其致命的牙齿、气息和舌头，它们所要做的就是给路过的一只哺乳动物，比如一头鹿或者别的什么，轻轻咬上一小口，然后所有的细菌就开始发挥作用，接着科莫多巨蜥就一路尾随那头鹿，鹿的病情慢慢加重，最后瘫倒在地，然后科莫多巨蜥就把它吃掉。谁是科莫多巨蜥？在这个类比中，是杰瑞米·亨特（Jeremy Hunt）。我想，大概是保守党吧。是的。所以我觉得这个结果确实有必要让我们回顾一下首相倒台的历史。绝对的。绝对的。而你，我一整天都在图书馆研究刺杀凯撒之类的事情，
but British prime minister as well very appropriate very appropriate but you have been drawing up your your list of the top 10 prime ministerial yes defenestrations because obviously most prime ministers by and large resign because they've lost an election exactly or they retire or they retire sort of stanley baldwin style um but be right there so there are there are two ways that people normally go either they go like stanley baldwin's they retire at the time of their own choosing that's pretty rare that gladstone as well i suppose you would say or they uh are defeated they lose an election and then that's the end of their premierships that's what you might call the jim callahan model or the John Major or Gordon Brown. But obviously the most enjoyable
不过英国首相也很贴切，非常贴切。但你一直在拟定你的首相倒台榜单，前10名首相的——是的——罢免事件。因为很显然，大多数首相基本上都是因为输掉了大选而辞职的。没错。或者他们退休了，或者以斯坦利·鲍德温（Stanley Baldwin）那种方式退休。嗯，就在那儿——所以人们通常有两种离开方式，要么像斯坦利·鲍德温那样，在自己选择的时机退休，这相当罕见，我想格莱斯顿（Gladstone）也可以算作这种；要么他们被击败，输掉大选，然后他们的首相生涯就此结束。这就是你所谓吉姆·卡拉汉（Jim Callaghan）模式，或者约翰·梅杰（John Major）或戈登·布朗（Gordon Brown）的模式。但很显然，最引人入胜的
ones, as your House of Cards analogy suggests, the most enjoyable ones are the regicides, the internal party coups. And anybody who was alive in 1990, who remembers that amazing symbiosis with the Thatcher downfall on the news and House of Cards playing at exactly that point. I just watched the opening again yeah and it opens with francis urquhart sitting in the whips office looking at a picture of mrs thatcher and then kind of saying all careers must end and laying it flat on the table and this went out exactly the time she was extraordinary timing extraordinary serendipity although although it's not serendipity though that's the thing, because there was a sense at the end of the 1980s that Mrs. Thatcher's race was run.
正如你的《纸牌屋》类比所暗示的那样，最引人入胜的当属弑君事件，也就是党内政变。任何经历过1990年的人，都记得那种奇妙的共生关系：新闻里播放着撒切尔夫人的倒台，而《纸牌屋》恰好在那个时刻上演。我刚才又看了一遍片头。是的，片头是弗朗西斯·厄克特坐在党鞭办公室里，看着一张撒切尔夫人的照片，然后说了句“所有政治生涯终有尽头”，并把它平放在桌子上。而这段播出的时间正好是她——真是非同寻常的时间巧合，非同寻常的机缘巧合。不过，这其实并非机缘巧合，这就是重点所在，因为在20世纪80年代末，人们有一种感觉，觉得撒切尔夫人的气数已尽。
And I think there's that sense of gathering momentum. There's that sense that in Westminster, the tide has turned against you. You see it reflected in the pages of the newspapers day after day. And everybody knows. It's like the end of the end of you know a season of game of thrones when everybody knows so-and-so's head is gonna fall a quickening in the praetorian camp exactly yes exactly yes okay so that being so um you've drawn up your list top 10 yeah what is your what is your first one so the first one is chronologically right yeah let's do it chronologically um and let's the first one is the first one. So it's Sir Robert Walpole. So Robert Walpole, as most of our listeners will know,
而且我觉得那种汇聚的势头非常明显。在威斯敏斯特，人们能感觉到潮流已经对你不利。你日复一日地在报纸版面上看到这种反映。每个人都知道。就像《权力的游戏》（Game of Thrones）某一季的结局，当所有人都知道某人的脑袋要落地时。近卫军营里的躁动。完全正确，是的，完全正确。好吧，既然如此，嗯，你列出了你的前十名榜单。对。你的第一位是谁？所以第一位按时间顺序来。对，让我们按时间顺序来。嗯，第一位就是第一位。所以他是罗伯特·沃波尔爵士（Sir Robert Walpole）。罗伯特·沃波尔爵士，正如我们大多数听众所知，
the first prime minister, he becomes prime minister in 1721. So by 1742, he's been prime minister, Tom, for more than 20 years. He's a great character. He's quite Boris Johnsonian. So he's very earthy, and he makes a virtue of his humanity. He sort of says he's no Puritan. He's no reformer or all this sort of thing. He's incredibly corrupt.
作为第一位首相，他在1721年成为首相。因此到了1742年，汤姆，他担任首相已经超过20年了。他是个了不起的人物。他很有鲍里斯·约翰逊式的风格。他非常接地气，并以自己的有人情味为荣。他曾说自己不是清教徒。他不是改革者或诸如此类的人。他极其腐败。
He's basically, he has made Britain rich, but he's also kept Britain out of foreign wars, which has upset a lot of people, the so-called Patriot Whigs. And there's a definite sense i think by the beginning of the 1740s that you know he's old the momentum has has moved turned against him he is forced slightly against his will to get britain into war with spain and the war of jenkins's ear right yes which you may remember from our episode on weird wars yeah um so jenkins was a he was a british merchant who had his ear chopped off yeah supposedly by the spanish years before wasn't it absolutely disgraceful spanish
基本上，他让英国变得富有，但他也让英国远离了外国战争，这惹恼了许多人，也就是所谓的“爱国辉格党人”（Patriot Whigs）。到了1740年代初，有一种非常明确的感觉，那就是他老了，势头已经发生变化，对我不利。他有点违背意愿地迫使英国卷入了与西班牙的战争，也就是詹金斯的耳朵之战，对吧？是的，你可能还记得我们关于奇怪战争的那期节目。所以，詹金斯是一个英国商人，他的耳朵被割了下来，是的，据说几年前被西班牙人割掉的，难道不是吗？西班牙人的行为简直令人发指，
behavior um which was obviously obviously the pretext for this war basically because you know we wanted to be to supplant spain in the caribbean and so on um but that doesn't go terribly well so we lost the battle of Cartagena in 1741. And here's the interesting thing that sets a bit of a sort of template. So in January 1742, there was a move in Parliament to have a commission to investigate the handling of the war. And that was basically seen, that's an attack, a full-scale attack on Walpole, because Walpole is administer of the war. And that was basically seen, that's an attack, a full-scale attack on Walpole,
这显然是这场战争的借口，基本上是因为我们想在加勒比海等地取代西班牙的地位等等，但这进展得并不顺利——所以在1741年，我们输掉了卡塔赫纳战役（Battle of Cartagena）。有趣的是，这里开创了一个某种模板。所以在1742年1月，议会中有人动议成立一个委员会来调查对这场战争的处理。这基本上被视为一次攻击，对沃波尔的全方位攻击，因为沃波尔是战争的管理者。这基本上被视为一次攻击，对沃波尔的全方位攻击，
because Walpole is administering the war. And that was defeated by only three votes. So in a way- A Pyrrhic victory. That's what so often happens in these stories. You get a Pyrrhic victory, and then just a little later, the final blow kind of falls. And that's exactly what happens
因为沃波尔负责管理这场战争。而这个动议仅仅以三票之差被否决了。所以从某种意义上说——惨胜。这种事在这些故事里经常发生。你得到了惨胜，然后过不了多久，致命的一击就降临了。这正是所发生的事情。
and the sort of komodo dragon in this the sort of final blow of the komodo dragon in this case is it's a it's very bizarre it's an argument about a by-election chippenham so that's one of the weird things about about old old political history is that often the sort of the trigger is the most banal and but by elections i mean you know so hanging over boris johnson now are the results of the two violations coming up in the red wall i know and in in the tory heartland so actually by elections are a kind of crucial markers of political health so what had happened is in 1741 there had been a general election which as as so often happened in those days took about 18 months or something there would been a general election which as as so often happened in those days took about 18 months something election and chippenham had two seats had two mps you know obviously manchester or
而其中的科莫多巨蜥，这种情况下科莫多巨蜥的最后一击，非常诡异，是一场关于奇彭纳姆（Chippenham）补选的争端。这是古老政治史怪异的地方之一，通常导火索是最平庸的。不过说到补选，我的意思是，现在悬在鲍里斯·约翰逊头顶的是红墙地区即将到来的两场补选结果，我懂，还有保守党腹地的补选。所以实际上，补选是政治健康状况的关键指标。事情的经过是这样的：1741年举行了一场大选，就像那个年代经常发生的那样，大选持续了大约18个月左右。举行了一场大选，就像那个年代经常发生的那样，大选持续了大约18个月左右，奇彭纳姆有两个席位，有两名议员，你知道，就像曼彻斯特或
birmingham has two so chippenham had um two and they'd both been won by the opposition um by sort of patriots or tories and um uh the government that the government two government candidates said they'd been very hard done by and this had been rigged and all this sort of thing and um in the end of january there was a vote in the house of commons to sort of have to throw out the chippenham mps and to have by elections which the government hoped they would win and it became a confidence measure and uh walpole lost it do you know how many how many votes he uh he lost it by some no lost it by one oh by one vote oh he lost two three five two three six that was the result and if he'd won it if he'd won it by one would he have
伯明翰有两个一样，所以奇彭纳姆有两个席位，并且都由反对派赢得——由所谓的爱国者或保守党人赢得。而且，政府的两位候选人声称他们受到了极大的不公正对待，这场选举被操纵了，诸如此类。1月底，下议院进行了一次投票，旨在罢免奇彭纳姆的议员并重新举行补选，政府希望他们能赢得补选。这变成了一场信任投票，而沃波尔输了。你知道他是以多少票之差输掉的吗？不，输了一票。哦，就以一票之差！哦，他以235比236票输了，这就是结果。如果他赢了，如果他仅仅赢了一票，他还能
staggered on no he did he was toast anyway because that that thing that happened james callaghan had a metaphor in 1979 very famously just before he lost to margaret thatcher he said there are times in politics when there's a sea change no matter what you do you know as prime minister the tide is against you and clearly for walpole um the tide was against him so he resigned um about about 10 days later uh he was george ii burst into tears when um i wonder if the queen will do the same when well when maybe sandwiches and walpole was given a pension of four thousand pounds a year which was a colossal astronomical amount of money he went off and bought gorgeous art didn't he which then got bought by catherine the great he died quite
勉强支撑下去吗？不，他无论如何都完蛋了。因为那种情况——詹金斯·卡拉汉（James Callaghan）在1979年就在击败玛格丽特·撒切尔之前非常著名地打过一个比喻，他说政坛有时会出现沧海桑田的巨变，无论你做什么，作为首相，潮流都对你不利。显然，对沃波尔来说，潮流对他是极其不利的，所以他大约在10天后辞职了。乔治二世甚至失声痛哭，当——我想当女王时，也许三明治（sandwiches）也是如此。沃波尔获得了一笔每年4000英镑的退休金，这是一笔极其庞大的巨款。他拿着钱去买精美的艺术品了，不是吗？后来这些艺术品被叶卡捷琳娜大帝买下了。他不久后就去世了，
soon afterwards um i can't actually remember He did, but he died quite soon afterwards. I can't actually remember how long afterwards, but it was quite soon afterwards anyway. And do you know who succeeded him, Tom? I know you're very familiar with our second prime minister. Can't remember. I had to look it up. I don't think anybody listening to this will know.
我实际上不记得——他确实去世了，但不久之后就去世了。我其实记不清具体是多久以后了，但反正很快就去世了。你知道是谁接替了他吗，汤姆？我知道你对我们的第二任首相非常熟悉。记不清了。我得查一下。我想听这个节目的任何人都不会知道。
It was the Earl of Wilmington. The Earl of Wilmington, of course. A name to conjure with. Yes. Okay. So Walpole, as in so many things, blazes the path. Yes. That's the template.
是威尔明顿伯爵（Earl of Wilmington）。威尔明顿伯爵，当然了。一个让人浮想联翩的名字。是的。好吧。所以沃波尔就像在许多事情上一样，开辟了先河。是的。这就是模板。
So that's number one. Number two? So number two is a prime minister who is often regarded as one of our worst, absolute worst prime ministers. And American listeners, whenever we talk about prime ministers, would always say on Twitter, well, obviously your worst was Lord North. Lord North, yeah. Do you know, I discovered while researching this, that Lord North wasn't actually his official title. It was only a sort of courtesy
所以这是第一位。第二位呢？第二位是一位通常被视为我们最糟糕、绝对是最糟糕的首相之一的首相。每当我们在节目里谈到首相时，美国听众总是在推特上说，好吧，显然你们最糟的是诺斯勋爵（Lord North）。诺斯勋爵，是的。你知道的，我在查资料时发现，诺斯勋爵实际上并不是他的正式头衔。这只是一种礼节性的
title and his real title was the Earl of Guildford. Well, Guildford got off luckily there. It did. So Lord North, like Walpole, had been in a very, very long time. So he'd been in since 1770. So we're into the reign of George III now. It's now 1782. The most famous thing of Lord North, obviously, he completely fails to conciliate the American colonies and basically presides over the American War of Independence, which goes very badly. And this is an interesting one because Lord North is clearly not personally solely responsible for the loss of the American colonies. But he's a good example of the way in which a particular individual um who who appears to have been kind of effortlessly all-conquering can become this sort of totem the sacrificial lamb i'm mixing my metaphors horrendously a bit
头衔，他的真实头衔是吉尔福德伯爵（Earl of Guildford）。好吧，吉尔福德在那方面算挺幸运的。确实如此。所以诺斯勋爵和沃波尔一样，在位时间非常非常长。他从1770年就开始任职了。所以我们现在进入了乔治三世的统治时期。已经是1782年了。诺斯勋爵最著名的事情，很显然，他完全无法安抚美洲殖民地，基本上主持了美国独立战争，而这场战争进展得非常糟糕。这是一个有趣的例子，因为诺斯勋爵显然并非个人独自应为美洲殖民地的丧失负全部责任。但他是一个很好的例子，说明了某一个特定的个人——
i mean it's it's a humiliating collapse i mean it's a humiliating blow to british prestige it's the collapse of his foreign policy so yeah and if he's had an effortless rise you could conceivably compare him to anthony eden who like i mean i know he doesn't resign immediately after yeah the suez crisis but he kind of goes off and has recuperative holiday in caribbean doesn't he but then he resigns and they and david cameron well i was going to say david cameron might not be a bad analogy but i think interest so david fun funnily enough, David Cameron is quite similar in the sense that there's this sort of effortlessness and this sort of chillaxing, which at first people thought of as a refreshing change after Gordon Brown throwing remote controls at people or whatever and biting his nails. But then becomes a stick with which to beat him.
他似乎毫不费力地就战胜了一切——如何变成这样一种图腾，一只替罪羊。我把比喻混合得一塌糊涂。我的意思是，这是一次耻辱性的崩溃，对英国威望来说是一个沉重的打击，标志着他的外交政策破产。所以，是的。如果他的崛起毫不费力，你或许可以把他比作安东尼·伊登（Anthony Eden）。安东尼·伊登虽然不是在苏伊士运河危机之后立即辞职，但他也是去加勒比海度假疗养，不是吗？但随后他辞职了，还有大卫·卡梅伦（David Cameron）。我本想说大卫·卡梅伦可能也是个不错的类比，但我认为有趣的是——说来有趣，大卫·卡梅伦与他相当相似，因为那种毫不费力的姿态，那种“chillaxing”（放松）的态度，起初人们认为这是一种令人耳目一新的改变，相比于戈登·布朗朝人扔遥控器或者咬指甲之类的事情。但后来这成了殴打他的大棒。
Well, Lord North, he's also accused of being sort of indolent and sort of- Well, Cameron and Lord North have quite similar faces. I mean, kind of- Oh, this is the thing with Lord North. Rubicond and round. This is the thing with Lord North. Lord North looks like a very fat child in a wig. He's really not flattered by his portrait.
好吧，诺斯勋爵也被指责为懒散以及——好吧，卡梅伦和诺斯勋爵长得挺像的。我的意思是，某种程度上——哦，这就是诺斯勋爵的问题。红光满面，圆脸。这就是诺斯勋爵的特点。诺斯勋爵看起来像个戴着假发的胖乎乎的小孩。他的画像真的没有把他拍得很好看。
And the weird thing is that actually i believe the consensus among those historians who still do 18th century political history is that lord north was actually quite a good prime minister right and he the the oxford dictionary of national biography says no prime minister in our history has ever had such command of parliament it was a sort of financial wizard and very popular and all this sort of thing i mean cameron also had a kind of aura of i mean he commanded the house and he did yeah he did as regarded as a he looked like a man who could never lose and then he did and then he spectacularly did yeah yes okay so so what happens with lord north is um the british have surrendered at yorktown in october 1781 the war is quite clearly lost, not least because of French intervention, which makes it really
奇怪的是，我相信那些至今仍在研究18世纪政治史的历史学家们的共识是，诺斯勋爵实际上是个相当不错的首相。没错。牛津《国家人物传记词典》（Oxford Dictionary of National Biography）说：“我们历史上的历任首相中，没有任何人能像他那样对议会拥有如此强的掌控力。”他是个理财奇才，非常受欢迎，诸如此类。我的意思是，卡梅伦也有一种——我的意思是，他掌控了下议院，他确实做到了。他被视为一个看起来永远不会失败的人，然后他失败了，而且输得极其壮观。是的，没错。好吧，所以诺斯勋爵的情况是——
impossible to keep sending troops to North America. But the war has always been opposed. I mean, that's one thing that we often forget about the American Civil War is there are lots of people in Britain who actually, there are quite a lot of people who actually support the Americans because they don't regard them as foreigners. They're regarded as a kind of almost a British civil war. At the end of February 1782, there's a motion to end further prosecution of the war in North America. And this is basically equivalent of your Walpole Chippenham vote. And Lord North loses that vote by 234 to 215 in the House of Commons. And that basically is the end of him. So he, again, in that sort of rather strange way
英国人在1781年10月于约克镇投降，战争显然已经输了，很大程度上是因为法国的干预，这使得继续向北美派兵变得完全不可能。但这场战争一直遭到反对。我的意思是，这是我们经常忘记关于美国独立战争的一点，那就是英国有很多人其实——有相当多的人实际上支持美国人，因为他们不把美国人视为外国人。这几乎被视为一场英国国内的内战。1782年2月底，出现了一项动议，要求停止在北美继续进行战争。这基本上相当于你说的沃波尔的奇彭纳姆投票。诺斯勋爵在下议院以234票对215票输掉了那次投票。这基本上就是他的终点。所以，他又以那种在早期英国政治史中相当奇怪的方式，
that happens with sort of early British political history, there's then a sort of, the resignation which you would expect to come the next day actually comes a month later. So there's lots of sort of faffing around. So he takes longer than Cameron. There's a lot of, yeah, there's lots of hanging around
本应在第二天进行的辞职，实际上推迟了一个月才发生。所以有很多拖沓闲晃的情况。所以他花的时间比卡梅伦还要长。有很多，是的，有很多闲逛的举动，
and presumably sort of gambling, port drinking. So that's more Anthony Eden. Betting on hot air balloons, whatever. Yes, all that kind that kind of stuff yeah doesn't lord north make a slight comeback he does yes he does make a bit of a comeback actually so he's still involved in senior politics years afterwards he succeeded so the the baton passes to the so to the people who had supported the americans basically who had been against the war so first of all rockingham and then to lord shelburne but north hangs around for a bit afterwards he's not completely discredited so in that sense he's so alec douglas hume tom oh yeah very good yes that's your lord north analogy okay
大概是在赌博、喝波特酒。所以那更像是安东尼·伊登。打赌热气球之类的。是的，诸如此类的事情。诺斯勋爵后来有没有稍微东山再起？有的，是的。他确实算是有所东山再起。几年后他依然参与了高级政治。他接替了——所以权力交给了那些支持美国人、基本上反对战争的人。首先是罗金汉（Rockingham），然后是谢尔本勋爵（Lord Shelburne）。但诺斯在之后还晃荡了一段时间，他并没有完全声名狼藉。从这个意义上说，他是阿历克·道格拉斯-休姆（Alec Douglas-Home）。汤姆，哦，对，没错！这就是你的诺斯勋爵类比。好吧，
so that so that's lord north um and then your third choice is actually the one that i thought of immediately because of course you know you could stop being prime minister not just because you've lost a vote of confidence or whatever yeah but because you're dead yes yes your third one is the only british prime minister have to have been assassinated spencer percival spencer percival again a man who's slightly hard done by by his portrait i think because if you look at spencer percival he looks incredibly boring and i think actually he was incredibly boring. So he would get sort of points today because he was a great abolitionist. He was opposed to slavery. But it doesn't stop him. He gets murdered by an irate scouser, doesn't he?
所以那是诺斯勋爵。然后你的第三个选择实际上是我立刻想到的，因为当然了，你不再担任首相不仅是因为你输掉了信任投票之类的，还因为你死了。是的，没错。你的第三个选择是英国历史上唯一一位被刺杀的首相：斯宾塞·珀西瓦尔（Spencer Percival）。斯宾塞·珀西瓦尔，同样是一个被他的画像稍微亏待了的人，我觉得。如果你看看斯宾塞·珀西瓦尔，他看起来无聊透顶，而我觉得实际上他也确实无聊透顶。所以他今天可能会因为是一个伟大的废奴主义者而获得一些好评。他反对奴隶制。但这并没有阻止他。他被一个愤怒的利物浦人谋杀了，不是吗？
He does. So he'd been prime minister for two and a half years. He was a Pittite. So he's a disciple of William Pitt, very much a friend of the rest of his history. Well, so Pitt also, I mean, he dies in office. He does indeed. So that's another. Through gout, ulcers, and being a three-bottle man.
确实如此。他担任了两年半的首相。他是皮特派（Pittite）。所以他是小威廉·皮特（William Pitt）的追随者，非常符合《历史余音》的调性。好吧，所以皮特也是——我的意思是，他在任上逝世了。他确实如此。所以这也是一个例子。死于痛风、溃疡，以及作为一个“三瓶酒男人”（three-bottle man）。
Yes, he's drinking. Oh, is it claret he gets prescribed? I think it was port, wasn't it? He was drinking three bottles of port a day in order to deal with his ulcers and his gout. And his alcoholism. Prescribed by his doctor. Yes, exactly. Great days. So Sir Percival, who's a very boring man.
是的，他酗酒。哦，那是医生给他开的红葡萄酒吗？我想是波特酒，对吧？他一天要喝三瓶波特酒来治疗他的溃疡和痛风。还有他的酗酒问题。医生开的处方。是的，完全正确。好日子。所以珀西瓦尔爵士，一个非常无聊的人。
Well, actually, Pitt was quite chilly, apart from the drinking. But Spencer Percival seems quite a boring man, although he does have 12 children, aged between 3 and 20 at the time of his death, which is quite a family holiday. Anyway, he's been Prime Minister. He's not terribly interesting. Obviously,'re in the napoleonic wars um there's a lot of partly because of the or largely because of the wars the economy is in a bad way there's lots of unemployment there's lots of industrial unrest in the north lud luddism the luddites are in full cry so they're they're indignant weavers smashing smashing looms smashing up looms exactly so so spencer percival is on his way to a parliamentary committee to investigate the luddites and he on
不过说实话，皮特除了酗酒之外也相当冷漠。但斯宾塞·珀西瓦尔看起来是个挺无聊的人，尽管他在去世时确实有12个孩子，年龄在3岁到20岁之间，这对全家度假来说是个不小的规模。无论如何，他担任了首相。他并不是非常有趣。显然，我们正处于拿破仑战争时期，嗯，很大程度上由于战争的原因，经济状况很糟，失业率很高，北方有大量的工业动荡，卢德运动（Luddism），卢德分子正在大声疾呼，他们是愤怒的织工，砸毁织布机，砸毁织布机，完全如此。所以斯宾塞·珀西瓦尔在前往一个调查卢德分子的议会委员会的路上，
the 11th of may 1812 and he goes into the house of commons lobby and a man called john bellingham is there now john bellingham as you described him an indignant scouter john bellingham is a failed merchant who's been imprisoned for bankruptcy in russia for five years or something wasn't it i mean a long time for a long time but he believes that the british government should compensate him yeah for his uh because he blames britain's sort of uh he thinks it's our fault for all our sort of orders and counsel and stuff that have been restricting trade and that he's a victim of our napoleonic war policy and he he went along to the foreign office a few days before and said he was in a great state about this. And Spencer Percival personally should be compensating him.
在1812年5月11日，他走进了下议院大厅，一个名叫约翰·贝林汉姆（John Bellingham）的人在那里。现在，约翰·贝林汉姆，正如你所描述的那样，是个愤怒的利物浦人。约翰·贝林汉姆是一个破产商人，曾在俄罗斯因破产被监禁了五年左右，不是吗？我的意思是，关了很长很长时间。但他认为英国政府应该赔偿他的损失，因为他把英国的某种——他认为是我们的错，因为我们所有的贸易禁令等限制了贸易，他是我们拿破仑战争政策的受害者。他几天前去过外交部，说他为此感到非常焦虑。并且斯宾塞·珀西瓦尔应该亲自赔偿他。
And the bloke at the Foreign Office said, you must do whatever you think best. So Belliam went out and got a gun. And anyway, he shoots Spencer Percival. Do you know what Spencer Percival's last words were, Tom? I've been murdered. Yes. He said, oh, I do. Yeah. But isn't, I mean, it's very shakespearean i'm slain kind of but isn't bellingham's motive as i
外交部的那个人说：“你觉得怎么做最好，就怎么做吧。”于是贝林汉姆出去买了一把枪。不管怎样，他枪击了斯宾塞·珀西瓦尔。你知道斯宾塞·珀西瓦尔的遗言是什么吗，汤姆？“我被谋杀了。”是的。他说：“哦，我真的——”是的。但难道不觉得，这非常莎士比亚吗？“我被杀了”之类的话。但贝林汉姆的动机，正如我
remember is that he shoots percival because he wants an opportunity to make his case well that's partly so so he will be accused and then he can stand up in the dock and say you all owe me money which which is a you know it's an original it's definitely a high risk policy but original well this is the thing because bellingham doesn't there's so much consternation when spencer percival has been shot and is shouting i've been murdered and people are sort of milling around and stuff and onlookers said bellingham could have just walked out of the lobby yeah he just sits there but he doesn't he sits down on a bench and he's got another he's got another loaded pistol with him and clearly is is very keen to be
所记得的那样，难道不是因为他枪击珀西瓦尔是为了寻找一个机会来陈述自己的案情吗？部分是这样——所以他会被指控，然后他就可以站在被告席上说“你们都欠我钱”，这（你知道的）很有创意，绝对是一个高风险的政策，但很有创意。这就是问题所在，因为当斯宾塞·珀西瓦尔被枪击并大喊“我被谋杀了”，人们四处张望、一片混乱时，贝林汉姆其实有很多机会直接走出大厅。旁观者说贝林汉姆本可以径直走出大厅的，但他没有，他只是坐在一张长凳上，身上还有另一支装满子弹的手枪，显然非常渴望被——
and and when he then goes on trial a few days later he sort of as you say tom he's he he makes a great point of saying well you know i'm the real person because my russian business is i mean actually dominic cummings had a business in Russia. I'll tell you how I know about this is that Lord Byron hears about it because he's obviously in the House of Lords. So he hears about it and he goes off
几天后他受审时，正如你所说，汤姆，他郑重其事地表示：“好吧，我才是真正受委屈的人，因为我在俄罗斯的生意——”实际上，多米尼克·库明斯（Dominic Cummings）也曾在俄罗斯做过生意。我之所以知道这件事，是因为拜伦勋爵（Lord Byron）听说了，因为他当时显然在上议院。所以他听说了这件事，然后他就去参加了一个
and he goes to a dinner party where Wordsworth is. And it's the first time that Byron and Wordsworth have met. And Byron bursts in and says the Prime Minister's been shot. So it's the first time that Wordsworth and Byron meet.
有华兹华斯（Wordsworth）出席的晚宴。那是拜伦和华兹华斯的第一次见面。拜伦冲进来宣布首相被枪杀了。所以那是华兹华斯和拜伦的第一次见面。
And they kind of, they bond over. That's a good fact tom over them and then they have a massive bust up afterwards but uh that that's a great there's a great book in that isn't it yeah pence and percival john bellingham byron wordsworth wordsworth it's all there it's all happening okay so that's so so death is obviously a very dramatic way. That's an outlier though, isn't it? That is an outlier. Okay. So much more common is some spectacular parliamentary bust up, which is precisely what we get with your fourth choice,
他们通过这件事建立了一种纽带。这是个好事实，汤姆。他们因为这件事产生了共鸣，然后他们后来闹翻了。但那里面绝对能出一本好书，不是吗？斯宾塞·珀西瓦尔、约翰·贝林汉姆、拜伦、华兹华斯，应有尽有，好戏连台。好吧，所以死亡显然是一种非常戏剧性的退出方式。但那是个特例，不是吗？那确实是个特例。好吧。更常见的是某种轰动性的议会决裂，而这恰好符合你的第四个选择，
who is actually a friend of Lord Byron. So continuing the Byronic theme, Robert Peel, who was at Harrow with Byron. Of course he was. So Robert Peel, he's twice prime minister, 1830s and 1840s, son of a manufacturer. So he's twice prime minister 1830s and 1840s son of a manufacturer so he's the first kind of industrial representative of industrial england of the industrial revolution to be prime minister um born in berry and then tamworth goes up in tamworth we discussed before didn't we whether
他实际上是拜伦勋爵的朋友。延续拜伦主题，罗伯特·皮尔（Robert Peel），曾与拜伦一同在哈罗公学（Harrow）就读。他当然在那儿读过。所以罗伯特·皮尔，他曾两次担任首相，分别在19世纪30年代和40年代，是一位制造商的儿子。所以他两次担任首相，在19世纪30年代和40年代，是一位制造商的儿子。因此他是第一位代表工业英国、工业革命的工业界代表首相，出生于伯里（Bury），后来发迹于塔姆沃思（Tamworth）。我们之前讨论过，不是吗？关于
he would have had there's some discussion about robert peel's accent whether he had a sort of staffordshire accent which i like to think he did. But he's the sort of founding father in some ways of liberal conservatism with his Tamworth Manifesto of 1834, which said, we just shouldn't be mindless ultra reactionaries. We should try to accommodate sometimes to the modern world. Just be kind. Yeah. Well, I don't know whether he's quite be kind. He's all about EDI, is Robert Peel. Anyway, so Robert Peel, his big thing is that, I mean, he really is the sort of Jeremy Hunt of his day because he's much more emollient than some Tories.
罗伯特·皮尔的口音，他是否带有某种斯塔福德郡口音，我更倾向于认为他有。在某种程度上，他是自由保守主义的奠基人，其标志是1834年的《塔姆沃思宣言》（Tamworth Manifesto），其中写道，我们不应该盲目做极端反动派，有时应该试着适应现代世界。要友善一点。好吧，我不知道他是不是那种“要友善一点”的人。罗伯特·皮尔非常注重多元、平等与包容（EDI）。无论如何，罗伯特·皮尔最大的特点是——我的意思是，他确实是他那个时代的杰瑞米·亨特，因为他比某些保守党人要温和得多。
And his big sort of – I mean, he has – Does he have a fully sprung ballroom, which is what Jeremy Hunt has? A fully sprung ballroom? Which is what Jeremy Hunt has. A fully sprung ballroom? Yeah. At his house. Jeremy Hunt is rich. He has his own ballroom. Fully sprung.
他最大的那种——我的意思是，他有——他是不是有一个装有弹簧的豪华舞厅？就像杰瑞米·亨特有的那样？一个有弹簧的舞厅？就像杰瑞米·亨特有的那样。一个有弹簧的舞厅？对。在他的宅邸里。杰瑞米·亨特很有钱。他有自己的舞厅。带弹簧的。
He's a very, very keen ballroom dancer. I can well believe he's a ballroom dancer. Yes, very good on Strictly. Very smooth. Well, maybe if this business doesn't work out for him, then Strictly awaits. Actually, Boris Johnson is such a St a strictly wannabe, isn't he? Yeah. I mean, he'd never get past here being around now, would he?
他是一个非常非常热衷于交谊舞的人。我完全相信他是个交谊舞者。是的，在《严格来跳舞》（Strictly Come Dancing）节目里一定表现很好。非常流畅。好吧，也许如果从政对他的生意没有起色的话，那么《严格来跳舞》正等待着他。说实话，鲍里斯·约翰逊是个十足的《严格来跳舞》狂热追求者，不是吗？是的。我的意思是，他现在绝对通不过初选，对吧？
Well, he might be a sort of John Sargent and Widdicombe type. Yeah, maybe. I know, I don't think so. Maybe enough time would. Anyway, listen, we're... Anyway, let's stick to Robert Peel. Sorry. So Robert Peel, yes.
嗯，他可能会成为约翰·萨金特（John Sargent）或安妮·威迪科姆（Ann Widdecombe）那类型的选手。对，也许吧。我知道，我不这么认为。也许时间足够了。不管怎样，听着，我们——无论如何，我们还是回到罗伯特·皮尔身上吧。抱歉。所以罗伯特·皮尔，是的。
He's had two sort of semi-conversions. One is on Catholic emancipation, which he's become a believer in. And the other is the classic one is he was, the Tory party was the party of protectionism, of trade barriers to stop cheap food coming in to- Destroying England's green and pleasant land. To protect landowners' interests. And Peel, partly because of the Great Famine in Ireland, but also because obviously there's a huge demand
他经历过两次半的转变。一次是对天主教解放（Catholic emancipation）的态度，他成了这一主张的信仰者。另一个经典的转变是，保守党曾是贸易保护主义的政党，主张设立贸易壁垒以阻止廉价食品流入——摧毁英格兰绿色而美好的土地。以保护地主的利益。而皮尔，部分是因为爱尔兰的大饥荒，但也因为不断增长的城市对廉价食品有着巨大的需求，
for cheap food from the growing cities, he decides that Britain has to change, that it has to ditch the Corn Laws and embrace free trade. And what he basically does, I mean, in some ways, the parallel, I suppose, that people sometimes give is Theresa May. So we'll come to Theresa May later, but she's caught between two wings of the party and sort of ground between these two great millstones. And that basically is what happens with Peel, except the difference is that Theresa May slightly refused to choose, whereas Peel basically does choose and abandons the sort of right of his party. Also, I mean, Peel is an incredibly charismatic and eloquent man.
他认为英国必须改变，必须抛弃《谷物法》（Corn Laws），拥抱自由贸易。他基本上所做的是——从某些方面来看，人们有时会给出的类比，我想是特雷莎·梅。我们稍后会谈到特雷莎·梅，她被夹在党内的两翼之间，被这两块巨大的磨盘碾压。这基本上就是皮尔所遭遇的，除了不同之处在于特雷莎·梅有点拒绝做出选择，而皮尔基本上做了选择，抛弃了他党内的右翼。而且，我的意思是，皮尔是一个极具个人魅力和雄辩能力的人吗？
Is he that charismatic, though? Yes, I mean, Peel is an incredibly charismatic and eloquent man. Is he that charismatic though? Yes, I think he is. I think he is. I think people really admire him. They do admire him, but I think they respect him more than they love him. If you know, do you not think? I don't know.
他真的那么有个人魅力吗？是的，我的意思是，皮尔是一个极具个人魅力和雄辩能力的人。他真的那么有魅力吗？是的，我认为他是。我认为是的。我认为人们真的很崇拜他。他们确实崇拜他，但我认为比起爱戴他，人们更敬重他。你知道的，你不觉得吗？我不知道。
I don't know. I think, I don't know. You'd know better than me, but I always have the impression, Byron certainly thought he was a wonderful man. I think he wasn't easily impressed. I thinkron is misleading you tom maybe could be i mean he misled a lot of people byron's vampiric ways of um yes maybe maybe that's it anyway yeah so so basically by february where february 1846 peel has has said let's let's ditch the corn laws let's
我不知道。我觉得，我不知道。你比我更了解，但我总是有这种印象，拜伦绝对认为他是个了不起的人。我觉得他不容易留下深刻印象。我觉得拜伦在误导你，汤姆。也许有可能。我的意思是，他用拜伦式的那种吸血鬼般的手段误导了很多人——嗯，也许，也许就是这样。不管怎样，是的——所以基本上到了1846年2月，罗伯特·皮尔已经表示，让我们废除《谷物法》，让我们
have free trade 231 of his own mps turn against robert peel i mean that really is a rebellion and to get um the repeal of the corners through he has to rely basically on wig and radical votes so he's basically no longer dependent on any meaningful way upon his own party um but his cap his political capital is hemorrhaging all the time. And the most famous moment, which you alluded to, was the 15th of May, when there's this absolutely, which I reread today, this absolutely blazing attack on him by Benjamin, the young Benjamin Disraeli, who at that point is very reactionary. This is one of those things that, you know, you sort of read,
实行自由贸易。他的党内有231名议员背叛了罗伯特·皮尔，这绝对是一场叛乱。为了让废除《谷物法》的法案通过，他基本上不得不依赖辉格党人和激进派的投票。所以他基本上不再以任何有意义的方式依赖他自己的党派，但他消耗的政治资本却在不断流失。最著名的时刻，也就是你刚才提到的5月15日，当时发生了——我今天重读了这段——由年轻的本杰明·迪斯雷利（Benjamin Disraeli）对他的猛烈抨击。当时的迪斯雷利非常反动。这就是那种你会读到：
oh, there's some blazing parliamentary performance, and then you actually read it. And it's just a bit limp. It's just dollar-stitch water. So he accused Peel of huckstering tyranny. He said he was a burglar of other people's intellect. He said, if you scour the records from the days of the conquest, there is no statesman who has committed political petty larceny on such a scale.
“哦，有一场精彩绝伦的议会表现，”但当你真正去读它时，却发现有点软弱无力。简直是索然无味。所以他指责皮尔搞“兜售暴政”，称他是“别人智慧的江洋大盗”。他说：“如果你翻遍自征服时代以来的记录，也没有哪个政治家犯过如此规模的政治盗窃案。”
That's great, isn't it? I love Disraeli. So this kind of made Disraeli's name as this sort of great flamboyant orator. It basically just, everyone laughs and everyone has a whale of a time and peel is sunk basically so peel survives for just over another month and then he's defeated again over one of these bills that's sort of subsequently forgotten so it's an irish coercion bill which is about sort of law and order in ireland he's defeated on that and that is the end of him so he's another example of this is another kind of komodo dragon it is exactly because he's limping on peel is limping on for the best part of six months
这话说得真棒，不是吗？我喜欢迪斯雷利。所以这确立了迪斯雷利作为伟大华丽演说家的名声。基本上就是，每个人都在大笑，每个人都度过了一段狂欢的时光，而皮尔基本上就此沉沦了。所以皮尔又勉强维持了一个多月，然后他在另一项随后被遗忘的法案上再次遭到击败——这是一项关于爱尔兰法律与秩序的爱尔兰强制法案（coercion bill）。他在那项法案上被击败，这就走到了他的终点。所以他也是这方面的另一个例子，这又是另一种科莫多巨蜥，确实如此，因为皮尔在苦苦支撑，
but he is finished it's clear that he cannot continue he falls off his horse very soon afterwards disraeli of course eventually becomes prime minister and steals all peel's ideas so yes and so i mean in a way obliely, he's destroyed by tensions within the United Kingdom, between the constituent parts. Ireland, yeah. So, yes, so people being kind of brought down by arguments over what the relationship of Ireland to Great Britain should be. This is then a thing that runs through the rest of the 19th century. But with Peel, I think you can argue that Peel's slightly brought down by his own integrity, by his own principle. I don't think that's something that people will say about our current um whatever they think of him they won't say that boris johnson was a man
但他也完了。很显然他无法继续下去了。不久之后他就从马背上摔了下来。迪斯雷利当然最终成为了首相，并窃取了皮尔的所有想法。是的，所以从某种迂回的意义上说，他是被联合王国内部各组成部分之间的紧张关系所摧毁的。爱尔兰，是的。所以，是的，人们因关于爱尔兰与大金王国关系的争论而被扳倒。这成了贯穿19世纪剩余时间的一个主题。但对于皮尔，我认为你可以说皮尔稍微是被他自己的正直、他自己的原则所击垮的。我不认为人们会对我们当前的——无论他们怎么看他，他们不会说鲍里斯·约翰逊是一个被自己——
toppled by his own but i mean gladstone is gladstone is basically destroyed by ireland as well isn't he he's not destroyed he's he's he resigns over it not ultimately so he does you're right that one of his premierships. I mean, Gladstone has, I think, four premierships. There's a third one. I think it's his third one. But he does then have a comeback in the 1890s when he's aged 380. So maybe Boris can look forward to that.
但我的意思是，格莱斯顿基本上也是被爱尔兰毁灭的，不是吗？他没有被毁灭，他是因此而辞职的，最终没有。所以你是对的，他的某一个首相任期。我的意思是，格莱斯顿我想有四个首相任期。这是第三个。我想是他的第三个任期。但他后来在19世纪90年代卷土重来时，他已经380岁了。所以也许鲍里斯可以期待这一点。
Yeah, exactly. Boris and Gladstone are the two most unlike prime ministers. Well, so, yes, okay. So our fifth on the topic of people who are actually quite like boris yeah um so your fifth is is asquith yeah prime minister in the first half of the first world war yes down by a very boris-esque character a very boris-esque character so asquith um who's very much a well he's a he's a friend of certainly this half of the rest is history askwith is a man who famously personifies the effortless superiority of the balial man tom um which i know you'll you'll enjoy that reference uh askwith has been prime minister
是的，完全如此。鲍里斯和格莱斯顿是两位最不相似的首相。好吧，所以，是的。那么第五位，谈到那些实际上与鲍里斯挺像的人——嗯，所以你的第五位是阿斯奎斯（Asquith），第一次世界大战前半段的首相。是的，被一个非常具有鲍里斯风格的人物扳倒。一个非常具有鲍里斯风格的人物。所以阿斯奎斯，他很大程度上是一个——嗯，他是一个——至少对《历史余音》这半边的我们来说是个朋友。阿斯奎斯是一个以其彻底体现了“贝利奥尔男儿”（Balliol man）的不费吹灰之力的优越感而闻名的人，汤姆——我知道你会喜欢这个梗。阿斯奎斯从1908年起担任首相，
since 1908 uh he is presided over all kinds of reforms isn't he he's well he's very well turned out at the beginning but he's distinctly shabby, I would say, at the end. Is he? He has, unfortunately, he has... Well, his clothes are still... But he's sort of... He's obviously drinking a lot, Asquith. And having unsuitable relationships. Yes.
他主持了各种各样的改革，不是吗？他一开始时衣着非常考究，但我可以说，到最后他明显变得破衣烂衫了。是吗？不幸的是，他有——好吧，他的衣服依然——但他显然——阿斯奎斯喝了很多酒，并且有着不合适的情感关系。是的。
And writing letters to girls and having picnics with people too young to be picnicking with. And reading novels during battles. Yes. And there were claims also that Asquith was a little bit handsy um but i don't know whether that's true or not i mean certainly by comparison with lloyd george asquith is an absolute okay so lloyd george is basically asquith's deputy yes he's his chancellor he's his right-hand man he's the radical firebrand the welsh wizard the the people the author of the people's budgets in the edwardian period um the sort of scourge of the tories and the dukes and the upper classes and they've been running the government but in but they've obviously taken britain into
还给年轻女孩写信，和那些年纪太小不适合野餐的人一起去野餐。在战斗期间读小说。是的。并且还有人称阿斯奎斯有点“手脚不干净”——但我不知道这是真是假。我的意思是，与劳合·乔治（Lloyd George）相比，阿斯奎斯绝对是个——好吧，所以劳合·乔治基本上是阿斯奎斯的副手，是的，他是他的财政大臣，他的得力助手，激进的煽动者，威尔士巫师，“人民预算”（People's Budgets）在爱德华时代的缔造者，保守党、公爵和上流社会的克星。他们一直在共同管理政府，但在——他们显然在1914年将英国带入了第一次世界大战。到1915年5月，他们不得不与保守党组建联合政府，因为他们因缺乏炮弹和把加利波利之战搞得一团糟而受到攻击。所以阿斯奎斯，在1915年、1916年，他的权威真的可以说是——我会说，随着把保守党人请进来，几乎每天都在流失。
the first world war in 1914 in may 1915 they have had to form a coalition with the tories because they've been attacked for not having enough shells and for making a mess of Gallipoli and stuff like that. So Asquith, in 1915, 1916, his authority really, I would say, is leaking away almost daily by inviting the Tories in. Do you say like air from a zeppelin? I would say like air from a zeppelin, Tom. That's a very nice parallel. So he's had to accept things that his heart isn't in. For example, conscription at the beginning of 1916.
你是说像齐柏林飞艇漏气一样？我会说像齐柏林飞艇漏气一样，汤姆。这是一个非常绝妙的类比。所以他不得不接受那些并非他本意的事情。例如，1916年初實行的征兵制。
It's not liberal, exactly. The Liberal Party and the Liberal creed is kind of crumbling under the pressure of the First World War. So in that sense it's a little bit like Peel. He's sort of trapped in this situation where the tectonic plates are shifting and he's going to end up the victim of situation where the tectonic plates are shifting and and he's
这并不完全是自由主义。自由主义政党和自由主义信条在一战的压力下有点崩溃了。从这个意义上说，这有点像皮尔。他有点陷入了这种板块移动的局势中，他最终将成为
going to end up the victim of it but actually what happens he really is completely and utterly stabbed in the back because lloyd george conspires with the tories and with the press lords as they were called so that's lord northcliffe lord rothermere and lord beaverbrook as he became i think um they they have a sort of they have a little plot that basically they'll keep Asquith on as an impotent figurehead, and that Lloyd George will really run the government through a war council. And they basically present this to Asquith. Asquith doesn't like it, not surprisingly. Lloyd George walks out, says, I won't serve under you then. know i'm out knowing really that the tories will back him lloyd george um askwith can't lead the government without lord george and without the tories or the unionists as they were called so that's the end of askwith has to resign and um lloyd george then
时局的牺牲品，但实际上发生的事情是，他真的被彻底地、无情地背后捅了一刀，因为劳合·乔治与托利党人以及当时所谓的报业大亨（也就是后来的北cliffe勋爵、罗瑟米尔勋爵和比弗布鲁克勋爵，我想嗯……）串通起来，他们搞了一个小阴谋，基本上就是让阿斯奎斯继续担任一个无能的傀儡，而劳合·乔治则通过战争委员会真正掌控政府。他们基本上把这个呈交给阿斯奎斯。不出所料，阿斯奎斯不喜欢这样。劳合·乔治拂袖而去，说那我不会在你手下效力了。我知道我出局了，心里其实很清楚托利党人会支持他。劳合·乔治，嗯……阿斯奎斯没有劳合·乔治和托利党人（或者当时所谓的统一党人）就无法领导政府，所以阿斯奎斯完了，不得不辞职，然后，嗯，劳合·乔治
becomes prime minister with tory support and that destroys the liberal party from that point on so lloyd george who is an absolutely i've said it before i'll say it again he is an absolutely terrible man i know the welsh listeners to the rest is history of whom there are there are millions um don't like this this claim but lloyd george he sold out all his principles he was a dreadful i mean he makes bor like, look, positively uxorious. Yeah, so absolutely accepting that. But he was a more effective war leader, wasn't he? Well, actually, the jury's a tiny bit out on that. So it's always been said that he's the man who won the war, that he, through ruthless determination and his peerless chairing of committees.
在托利党人的支持下成为了首相，从那一刻起，自由主义政党就被摧毁了。所以劳合·乔治——我以前说过，我还要再说一遍——他是个绝对糟糕透顶的人。我知道《历史的其余部分》的威尔士听众（有数百万之多）嗯……不喜欢这个说法，但劳合·乔治，他出卖了自己所有的原则。他是个可怕的……我的意思是，他把鲍（里斯）衬托得简直……显得非常宠爱妻子。是的，完全接受这一点。但他是个更有能力的战时领导人，不是吗？嗯，其实，这还有待商榷。所以人们总说他是赢得战争的人，他通过无情的决心和无与伦比的主席主持能力……
And his mighty moustache. Yeah, he leads Britain to victory. That's what hemingway thought wasn't it but there are big fan yeah but people who like great men and people who fancy who sort of get off on the idea of titanic men of ruthless vigor yeah sort of churchill napoleon kind of people basically andrew roberts people like that they love lloyd george and they look at asquith and they say what a simpering old fool you you know, reading novels and talking to girls. Sitting in gardens and things like that. Yeah.
以及他那威武的小胡子。对，他带领英国走向胜利。海明威就是这么认为的，不是吗？但有很大的粉丝……是的，但喜欢伟大人物的人，以及喜欢那种崇拜无情精力的泰坦式人物的人——是的，比如丘吉尔、拿破仑这样的人，基本上像安德鲁·罗伯茨这样的人——他们热爱劳合·乔治，他们看着阿斯奎斯说，你这个傻乎乎的老笨蛋，你知道的，只知道读小说和跟女孩子聊天。坐在花园里之类的事情。是的。
But actually Asquith was a perfectly good prime minister. So the theme there is rivalries within the same party. Yeah, being knifed by your- Which I guess is kind of happening in the 18th century, but I'm not aware of it to the same extent. And is it there with Disraeli or is Disraeli seizing his chance to make a name for himself what is really is the is the classic greasy pole but lloyd george and um uh asquith is the the classic prime minister and chancellor of the exchequer relationship which throughout the 20th century has you know been an absolute breeding ground for rivalry i would say yes there's that
但实际上阿斯奎斯是一个非常好的首相。所以这里的主题是同一政党内部的权力斗争。是的，被你的——这我想在18世纪也有发生，但我不太清楚它达到了同样的程度。迪斯雷利身上有这种现象吗？还是迪斯雷利在抓住机会为自己扬名立万？迪斯雷利其实是经典的“滑腻的政治阶梯”的代名词，而劳合·乔治和，嗯……阿斯奎斯则是首相与财政大臣关系的经典写照，在整个20世纪，这可以说是滋生权力斗争的绝对温床，我想是的，确实有这回事。
and i would also say beware the mountebank because disraeli lloyd george and boris johnson are all prime specimens of the sort of the flamboyant parliamentary mountebank who the public love they think their mountebanks are tremendous characters yeah yeah but of course boris basically did to theresa may what um lord george had done to her i mean he wasn't her chancellor but he he flounced out didn't he and but it is i mean it is a theme and we'll we'll i'm sure it is well i know for facts i can see your list it's going to come up again but the relationship between 10 downing street where the prime minister lives and 11 downing street where the chancellor lives it's incendiary it breeds a rivalry so what would
而且我还要说，当心那些政客骗子，因为迪斯雷利、劳合·乔治和鲍里斯·约翰逊都是那种花言巧语的议会政客骗子的典型代表，公众很喜爱他们，他们认为政客骗子是非常了不起的人物。对，对，但当然，鲍里斯基本上对特蕾莎·梅做的事，就是劳合·乔治对她做过的事——我的意思是，他虽然不是她的财政大臣，但他怒气冲冲地走了，不是吗？但确实，这就是一个主题——而且我们肯定会，我敢肯定——我看到你的清单了，这还会再次出现——唐宁街10号（首相官邸）和唐宁街11号（财政大臣官邸）之间的关系简直像火药桶一样，它滋生了权力的竞争。所以，
destroy boris johnson right now is if rishi sunak came out and said enough is enough you know the prime minister had been sent a very clear message well maybe he's already said we don't know what's happening while we were no it's like trapped in a bubble i mean it's like the big brother house yeah it is it's just actually love island is starting tonight dominic so it's like we're trapped on the love island the tragedy of this i not just for the country, but for the world, is that we've had to postpone our planned podcast about history's greatest Love Island couples because we've been too busy thinking about the foodling business of prime ministers. I know.
现在能摧毁鲍里斯·约翰逊的事情，就是如果里希·苏纳克站出来说，够了，你知道的，首相已经收到了非常明确的信息……好吧，也许他已经说了，我们不知道在我们……不，这就像被困在一个气泡里，我的意思是，这就像《老大哥》真人秀的房子。是的，确实是这样，实际上《爱情岛》今晚就要开播了，多米尼克，所以这感觉就像我们被困在了《爱情岛》上。这件事的悲剧不仅对国家，而且对世界来说，是我们不得不推迟我们原定的关于“历史最伟大《爱情岛》情侣”的播客节目，因为我们太忙于思考首相们的那些肮脏勾当了。我知道。
I know. Anyway, so I think we should go and take a break now. I might pop down and see what's happening on Love Island. Katie will give me an update, my daughter. Okay. You can find out what's happening in downing street and when we come back uh it will be to look at another prime minister who was toppled during a world war so i'm sure you can guess who it is but uh we will confirm it when we get back see you in a minute i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
我知道。不管怎样，我想我们现在应该去休息一下了。我可能会去看看《爱情岛》上正在发生什么。凯蒂会给我最新消息的，我的女儿。好的。你可以去了解唐宁街正在发生什么，当我们回来时，我们将去关注另一位在世界大战期间被推翻的首相，所以我想你肯定能猜到他是谁，但是，嗯，我们会在回来时确认。一分钟后见，我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back. We are recording this on a historic evening, Monday, the 6th of June. And Dominic, during the break, I popped down and discovered that Michael Owen's daughter apparently has just shacked up with someone.
我们共同主持《娱乐至上》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝八卦的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前获得现场门票的权益，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回来。我们在一个具有历史意义的夜晚录制这期节目，也就是6月6日星期一。多米尼克，在休息期间，我过去看了一下，发现迈克尔·欧文的女儿显然刚和某人好上了。
So that's very exciting. This is on Love Island. That's exciting. On Love Island. And Boris Johnson has announced that his disastrous result was extremely positive, decisive and conclusive. So it's all happening. It's all kicking off.
这太令人兴奋了。这是在《爱情岛》上。这太令人兴奋了。在《爱情岛》上。而鲍里斯·约翰逊则宣布，他的灾难性选举结果是极其积极、果断和具有决定性的。所以一切都在发生。一切都开始热闹起来了。
So you've given us five of your top 10. We've had Walpole. We've had Lord North. We've had Spencer Percival. We've had Peel. And we've had Asquith. So we've got five to go number six neville chamberlain so number six is neville chamberlain so if you just think about those five walpole and lord north are kind of the same story they've they've had their time uh the tide has turned against them um the game is up and then once the first blows start to fall it's obvious obvious they're out. Spencer Percival obviously shot.
所以你已经给我们介绍了你的前十名中的前五位。我们有沃波尔。我们有诺斯勋爵。我们有斯宾塞·珀西瓦尔。我们有皮尔。我们还有阿斯奎斯。所以我们还有五位要讲，第六位是内维尔·张伯伦。所以第六位是内维尔·张伯伦。如果你回想一下那前五位：沃波尔和诺斯勋爵基本上是同一类故事——他们的时代已经过去，大势已去，游戏已经结束，一旦第一击落下，他们显然就完蛋了。斯宾塞·珀西瓦尔显然是被枪杀的。
Robert Peel, to some extent, sacrificed his career for what he thought was right. And then number five, Asquith stabbed in the back by Shyster. Chamberlain, I would say, is Lord North-esque. He is Lord North-esque. Because his entire foreign policy has been torpedoed. Yes, it is. Basically, if your foreign policy gets torpedoed and you have humiliated your country, or as Prime Minister, you've left your country humiliated,
罗伯特·皮尔在某种程度上为了他认为是正确的事情牺牲了自己的职业生涯。然后第五位，阿斯奎斯被骗子背后捅刀。张伯伦，我要说，他带有诺斯勋爵式的色彩。他带有浓厚的诺斯勋爵色彩。因为他的整个外交政策都被彻底炸毁了。是的，确实如此。基本上，如果你的外交政策被炸毁，并且你让你的国家蒙受羞辱，或者作为首相，你让国家陷入屈辱的境地，
then I think you have to go, don't you? Well, here's the thing. So he's Lord North-esque in another sense, because he's Lord North-esque in that the image that everybody has of him now is this sort of weed, this weedy wind. And his wind collar. It's completely at variance with the reality of the time so chamberlain's taken britain into the second world war obviously the policy of appeasement has
那么我认为你就必须得走了，不是吗？好吧，情况是这样的。所以他在另一个意义上也带有诺斯勋爵式的色彩，因为他在人们心目中的形象现在就像那种软弱的人，这种软弱的风气。还有他的硬领。这与当时的现实完全不符。所以张伯伦把英国带入了第二次世界大战，显然绥靖政策已经
completely failed which is your analogy which is the the american war of independence you can imagine how yes what a bitter blow this is to me this is to me yeah oh exactly so he's taken britain into war with the least ringing, least warlike speech. Vladimir Zelensky, he is not. But in April 1940, so approval ratings, kind of Gallup ratings are in their infancy. His ratings are actually very, very good. They're north of 60%. Was this rallying to the flag, isn't there?
彻底失败了——这正是你的类比，也就是美国独立战争。你可以想象，是的，这对我是多么沉重的打击，这对我来说……哦，完全是这样。所以他带领英国参战时，发表了一篇最不慷慨激昂、最不像要打仗的演讲。他绝不是弗拉基米尔·泽连斯基。但在1940年4月，当时的支持率——盖洛普民调还处于起初阶段——他的支持率实际上非常非常高。超过了60%。这不是一种对国家的拥护吗？
There was a rallying to the flag. There was a sense that Mr. Chamberlain, with his mastery of the accounts... Which he had done his best, I think. Yeah, that he had done. Well, I think that was very important. Actually, I think Chamberlain is much maligned. And I think the fact that he had clearly done his best and tried to avoid war meant that Britain went into the Second World War. I know people have huge arguments about aircraft production.
这是一种对国家的拥护。当时有一种感觉，认为张伯伦先生凭借他对账目的精通……我认为他已经尽力了。是的，他已经尽力了。好吧，我认为这非常重要。实际上，我认为张伯伦被大大诋毁了。我认为他显然已经尽了最大努力并试图避免战争，这意味着英国进入第二次世界大战时……我知道人们对飞机生产有巨大的争论。
But what it definitely meant is that Britain went into the Second World War united with a consensus that we had done everything possible to avoid war. And now we were determined to wage it and win it, which I don't think would have been the case, actually, if we'd entered war earlier. Because there had always been people who said we should have given the Germans more chances. Anyway, what destroys him, his equivalent of Yorktown, is the invasion of Norway, the catastrophic debacle of all these people arriving in Norway with the wrong kits and getting lost in the snow and falling into the sea and fighting among themselves or whatever, while the Germans are kind of carrying all before them. Then we have this sort of shambolic withdrawal from Norway at the end of April 1940. And then on the 7th and 8th of May, there is this.
但它绝对意味着英国进入第二次世界大战时是团结一致的，并且达成了一种共识：我们已经尽一切可能避免了战争。而现在我们决心进行这场战争并赢得它。实际上，如果我们更早参战，我认为情况就不会是这样。因为总会有人说我们应该给德国人更多机会。不管怎样，摧毁他的是他的“约克镇时刻”——那就是入侵挪威，那是所有这些带着错误装备抵达挪威、在雪地里迷路、掉进海里、内讧等等的灾难性惨败，而德国人却一路势如破竹。接着在1940年4月底，我们迎来了这种混乱的撤军。然后在5月7日和8日，发生了这样一件事。
So this is the great debate. This is the sort of the only parallel for this, I think, is the fall of Margaret Thatcher and the Geoffrey Howe speech or the Israeli attack on Robert Peel. So it's the 7th and 8th of May. It's this famous Norway debate that you sort of see immortalized in the films and so on. Sir Roger Keyes, the MP for Portsmouth, turns up in his full admiral's uniform and absolutely denounces the government's handling of Norway. Leo Amory gives the famous speech, later... The name of God Go, is that the one? Yes. Depart, I say, and let us
所以这是一场伟大的辩论。我认为，对此唯一的类比只有玛格丽特·撒切尔的下台与杰弗里·豪的演讲，或者是迪斯雷利对罗伯特·皮尔的攻击。所以那是5月7日和8日。这就是那场著名的“挪威辩论”，你在电影等等作品中经常能看到它被永垂青史。朴次茅斯议员罗杰·基斯爵士穿着整套海军上将制服出现，对政府处理挪威问题的方式进行了彻底的谴责。利奥·埃默里发表了那篇著名的演讲，后来……“以神之名，滚开”，是那篇吗？是的。“离开吧，我说的，让我们”
have done with you. Later used by the Sun, I think, to describe Bobby Robson, Tom. Anyway, so there's a vote of... In the name of Alago, wasn't it? In the name of Alago after we drew with Saudi Arabia. I think it was. So I'm glad we've got that in.
“和你们了断吧。”后来好像被《太阳报》用来形容鲍比·罗布森，汤姆。不管怎样，所以有一场关于……是在“阿拉戈之名”下吗？在与沙特阿拉伯战平之后，是在“阿拉戈之名”下吗？我想是的。所以我很高兴我们把这个也涵盖进去了。
Very important. He had about a 200 majority, Chamberlain, but he won that confidence vote by only 81. And at that point, it was obvious to him and to everybody that with so many people, sort of 120 Tories either abstaining or voting against, that the game was up. Chamberlain is a very honourable man. And he basically says to his sort of advisors, I will resign unless Labour agree to have a coalition government with me
非常重要。张伯伦当时大约有200票的多数优势，但他赢得那场信任投票仅仅赢了81票。就在那个时候，对他和所有人来说都显而易见了——有那么多人，大约120名托利党人要么弃权要么投反对票——游戏已经结束了。张伯伦是一个非常正直的人。他基本上对他的顾问们说，除非工党同意与我组成联合政府，并由我继续担任首相，
as prime minister. Clement Attlee, the Labour leader, consults with the other sort of Labour bigwigs, and they say, no, they won't serve under Chamberlain, but they will serve under somebody else. And Chamberlain, he behaves admirably, actually. As a patriot. Exactly. Very patriotically. He basically organises the kind of consultation about who will succeed him. On the 10th of May, when he quits, he gives this, actually, when you read it, very moving resignation address where he says the whole country must unite around Churchill,
否则我就辞职。克莱门特·艾德礼，工党领袖，与其他几位工党大人物商量后表示，不，他们不会在张伯伦手下效力，但他们愿意在其他人手下效力。而张伯伦表现得非常令人钦佩，真的。作为一个爱国者。没错。非常爱国。他基本上组织了关于谁将接替他的磋商。在5月10日他辞职时，他发表了一篇——当你读到它时会觉得非常感人的辞职演讲，在演讲中他说整个国家必须团结在他的继任者丘吉尔周围。
his successor. And then Churchill asks him to stay on as Lord President of the Council, which he does. When Chamberlain goes back into the House of Commons, there's a tremendous ovation. I mean, everybody kind of cheers him. Which is a problem for Churchill, isn't it? Yes.
然后丘吉尔请他留任枢密院议长，他也照做了。当张伯伦回到下议院时，全场起立热烈鼓掌。我的意思是，所有人都为他欢呼。这给丘吉尔带来了麻烦，不是吗？是的。
Yeah, it's still chamberlain's party chamberlain recognizes this and in the crucial debate between him halifax and churchill he sides with chamberlain sides with churchill with churchill so chamberlain actually comes out of this story i would say extremely well as churchill recognizes and then when Chamberlain dies, he gives that kind of amazing thrannity on him. And Churchill offered him the Order of the Garter as he was dying. So he's dying of bowel cancer in August 1914. He dies in November.
是的，这仍然是张伯伦的政党。张伯伦意识到了这一点，在与哈利法克斯和丘吉尔的关键辩论中，他站在了——张伯伦站在了丘吉尔一边。所以张伯伦实际上从这个故事中脱颖而出，我要说，表现得极其出色，正如丘吉尔所承认的那样。后来当张伯伦去世时，他发表了一篇对他的惊人悼词。当张伯伦临终时，丘吉尔甚至授予了他嘉德勋章。当时他在1914（应为1940）年8月死于肠癌。他在11月去世。
Churchill says, would you like the Order of the Garter? And Chamberlain says, again, I think quite movingly, he says, no, I would prefer to die plain Mr Chamberlain like my father before me. So he does. I once went to a dinner party where we all had to read something that we found moving. This was part of the, this is what we do in London, Dominic. Yeah, of course. And I read Churchill's speech on mourning, you know, commemorating Chamberlain.
丘吉尔说：“你想获得嘉德勋章吗？”张伯伦再次以一种我认为相当感人的方式说：“不，我宁愿像我父亲那样，作为一个普通的张伯伦先生死去。”所以他确实如此。我曾经去参加一个晚宴，我们每个人都必须朗读一段让我们觉得感人的东西。这是……伦敦人就是这么干的，多米尼克。是的，当然。我读了丘吉尔关于悼念（张伯伦）的演讲。
And the woman next door to me was so infuriated by that she physically assaulted me and threw me off my chair. Are you serious? Yeah. I thought you were going to, when you start the antidote, when you said the woman next to me, I thought, oh, she was, she started crying. But no.
坐在我旁边的那位女士对此感到无比愤怒，以至于她对我进行了人身攻击，把我从椅子上推了下去。你是认真的吗？是的。当你开始讲这个轶事时，当你说“坐在我旁边的那位女士”时，我还以为哦，她哭了呢。但并没有。
Well, we're right. She was so furious. Why? I'm not quite sure. I don't know. I don't know what it was. Because even if she was anti-appeasement, the fact that Churchill was saying it would surely well that's extraordinary maybe she was a committed
好吧，我们说得对。她太生气了。为什么？我不太确定。我不知道。我不知道那是什么原因。因为即使她反对绥靖政策，丘吉尔说出那番话的事实也肯定……好吧，这太不可思议了。也许她是个坚定的
fan of lord halifax yes maybe i don't know anyway uh so i've always had a soft spot for chamberlain yeah quite rightly um i think he's great you've been you know there's lots of unlikable things about chamberlain but robert harris really humanizes him in his book munich which was made yeah i thought the film was very good with Jeremy Irons. I haven't seen the film, but I imagine Jeremy Irons would be very good as Chamberlain. Yeah, he was. Because what people get wrong about Chamberlain is Chamberlain was an incredibly sort of, he was a man of iron will and incredibly arrogant, sort of man of tremendous self-belief and
哈利法克斯勋爵的狂热粉丝？是的，也许吧，我不知道。不管怎样，所以我对张伯伦一直有一种特殊的好感。是的，完全正确。我认为他很棒。你对张伯伦有很多不喜欢的地方，但罗伯特·哈里斯在他的书《慕尼黑》（后来被拍成电影）中确实将他人性化了。我觉得杰瑞米·艾恩斯出演的那部电影非常棒。我没看过这部电影，但我能想象杰瑞米·艾恩斯演张伯伦会非常出色。是的，他演得很好。因为人们对张伯伦的误解在于，张伯伦是一个极其……他是一个意志坚定、极其傲慢、极其自信的人，
not at all this sort of pooterish weed that we now think of him. He was a man of the Midlands, wasn't he, Dominic? He was a man of the Midlands. He was like one of Tolkien'skien's hobbits right tom um so we've had a couple there's another couple of prime ministers who fall by the wayside in the next few years so obviously uh eden ill health well but interesting churchill who doesn't yeah so churchill people always go people who've seen the crown which you haven't dominic but the opening episode i have seen the first episode okay it. It's kind of endless.
绝不是我们现在所认为的那种迂腐的软弱之辈。他是一个来自米德兰兹的人，对吧，多米尼克？他是一个来自米德兰兹的人。他就像托尔金笔下的霍比特人一样，对吧，汤姆？嗯，我们已经经历了几位——在接下来的几年里，还有几位首相中途倒台——显然，埃登是因为健康状况不佳……不过有趣的是丘吉尔却没有——所以丘吉尔，人们总是去看……看过《王冠》的人（虽然你没看过，多米尼克，但我看过第一集）——好吧，第一集。这简直没完没了。
The political plot in that is people endlessly trying to get rid of Churchill, isn't it? What are we going to do about Mr. Churchill? So they're kind of going off and Anthony Eaton's sleeping off in a shooting party with George VI. Yeah. Well, basically what people are doing to Churchill is constantly saying, Winston, do you not think it's time? You know, the Mediterranean's right.
里面的政治阴谋就是人们没完没了地试图除掉丘吉尔，不是吗？我们该拿丘吉尔先生怎么办？所以他们到处串联，安东尼·艾登在与乔治六世的射击派对上打瞌睡。是的。好吧，基本上人们对丘吉尔做的事情就是不断地说：“温斯顿，难道你不认为时候了吗？你知道的，地中海那边……”
Yeah, Churchill then has another stroke and just refuses to go. Very Boris. So actually what that is a reminder of is that a prime minister is very hard to get rid of. If they don't want to go, they can be very hard to get rid of. So Churchill just refuses to go. Particularly if he'd just won the Second World War. Well, yeah, okay. I mean, that's a...
是的，丘吉尔后来又中风了一次，但就是拒绝离职。非常鲍里斯。所以实际上这提醒我们，一个首相是非常难被赶下台的。如果他们不想走，他们很难被赶走。所以丘吉尔就是拒绝离职。特别是如果他刚刚赢得第二次世界大战的话。好吧，是的，好吧。我的意思是，那是一个……
So Eden goes because he's gone off to golden eye in Fleming's house in Jamaica, but he's ill, isn't he? After the Suez crisis, his health has collapsed. It's an interesting question about whether people would have tried to force him out. Had he not resigned.
所以艾登下台了，因为他去了弗莱明在牙买加的房子“黄金眼”，但他生病了，不是吗？苏伊士运河危机之后，他的健康崩溃了。这是一个有趣的问题：如果他没有辞职，人们是否会试图逼他下台。
And it's still sort of, I think when he returned after Suez, Eden knew that the tide had turned against him. He had to go. I think that's, I think that is the lesson from Walpole through Lord North, through Chamberlain, that if your whole foreign policy has gone tits up, you've got to go.
而且这仍然……我认为当艾登在苏伊士运河事件后返回时，他知道大势已去。他必须离开。我认为这就是从沃波尔、诺斯勋爵到张伯伦身上得到的教训：如果你的整个外交政策彻底搞砸了，你就必须得走。
We're going to come to an example later on, the Theresa May example, of somebody who stays on basically for a long time. You can be a zombie. But like a goat who's been bitten by a komodo dragon okay anyway and mcmillan is the weirdest one isn't it because he gets told he's got terminal cancer and then he discovers oh no i haven't i've resigned damn well i think mcmillan kind of talks himself into thinking this he's a terrible hypochondriac mcmillan so mcmillan yes he has he wakes up in the night with a terrible pain in his bladder
我们稍后会讲到一个例子——特蕾莎·梅的例子——有人基本上在位很长时间。你可以当一个僵尸首相。就像一只被科莫多巨蜥咬了一口的羊一样。好吧，不管怎样，麦克米伦是最奇怪的一个，不是吗？因为他被告知他得了晚期癌症，然后他发现——哦，不，我没得，是我自己辞职了，该死。好吧，我觉得麦克米伦有点自我暗示，觉得自己快死了。麦克米伦是个严重的疑病症患者。所以麦克米伦，是的，他有一次半夜醒来，膀胱剧痛，
he can't go to the toilet. He gets a specialist in to see him. I haven't really ginned up on Macmillan for this, so I'm doing this from memory. And then he sort of says, oh, my God, I'm going to die. I resign. And then, yeah, exactly. Do you think he resigned? Do you think he resigned partly because he knew he was going to lose the next election?
他无法上厕所。他请了一位专家来看病。我没有为这个节目专门恶补麦克米伦的资料，所以我凭记忆在说。然后他就说，“哦，天哪，我要死了。我辞职。”然后，是的，完全是这样。你觉得他是辞职了吗？你觉得他辞职部分是因为他知道自己会输掉下一次选举吗？
Well, this is the thing. You see, the tide has clearly turned against Macmillan. Yeah. It was post-Perfumo. Peter Cook doing the merciless impressions of him and things. He's been prime minister since 1957. 63, the momentum, the cultural temperature has changed. He's an interesting example of someone who resigns because of hypochondria.
好吧，关键就在这里。你看，大势显然已经背离了麦克米伦了。是的。那是普富莫事件之后。彼得·库克对他的无情模仿等等。他自1957年以来一直担任首相。到了1963年，势头变了，文化氛围变了。他是一个因疑病症而辞职的有趣例子。
Yes, I guess so. But also, would he have resigned from hypochondria, Tom, two years earlier when he was in his pomp? I would say probably not. No, I would think probably not. I think there's a bit of him that thinks, oh, the game is a sod at the games of anyway. But this leads very, very neatly into your next choice.
是的，我想是的。但是，汤姆，如果在两年前他正处于全盛时期时，他会因为疑病症而辞职吗？我想大概不会吧。不，我想大概不会。我觉得他心里有一部分会觉得，哦，这游戏真没意思。但这非常非常巧妙地引出了你的下一个选择。
If it's someone who may actually have been incredibly ill, but doesn't resign. Yeah, Harold Wilson. Harold Wilson is your, what's that, eighth? Well, he's my seventh choice. But actually, I didn't choose him for 1976. harold wilson is your what's that eight well he's no seventh he's my seventh choice but actually i didn't choose him for 1976 i choose him for the late 60s because he's the one example actually of a prime minister who appears to be sunk but i mean people always would talk about uh harold wilson as a kind of india rubber man but he doesn't resign and he doesn't resign and you can't have
如果这是一个可能真的病得非常重，却没有辞职的人的话。是的，哈罗德·威尔逊。哈罗德·威尔逊是你的——那是第八个吗？好吧，他是我的第七个选择。但实际上，我选他不是因为1976年。哈罗德·威尔逊是你的——那是第八个吗？好吧，他不是，他是第七个，他是我的第七个选择。但实际上我选他不是因为1976年，我选他是因为60年代末期，因为他实际上是这样一个首相的唯一例子：他看起来已经要沉没（下台）了，但我的意思是人们总是把哈罗德·威尔逊称为某种“印度橡胶人”，但他就是不辞职，就是不辞职，你不能把他——
him for that and the constant plots against him which are which i mean from 1966 to 1970 the newspapers are dominated by stories about people plotting and wilson doesn't resign so the reason he's my number seven tom is because he's the one who bucks the trend no that's that that's that's not acceptable but i've i've chosen him no he's you can only have people who resign you can't have people who don't no because i think but then of course he does resign in 1976 exactly so that's what i thought you were doing it because i've surprised he gets alzheimer's doesn't he i've surprised you well why does he resign in 1976 it's not because he had and he's being bugged by the by mi5 and it's not because he always said he would do just a couple of years
因为那些针对他的不断阴谋——我的意思是，从1966年到1970年，报纸上充斥着关于人们密谋的故事，而威尔逊就是不辞职。所以他成为我的第七号选择，汤姆，因为他是那个打破常规的人。不，那、那、那是不可接受的，但我已经选了他——不，你只能选那些辞职的人，你不能选那些不辞职的人——不，因为我认为——但当然他在1976年确实辞职了。完全正确，所以我以为你选他是因为——我很惊讶他得了老年痴呆症，不是吗？我很惊讶你——好吧，他为什么在1976年辞职？不是因为他得了——而且他一直被军情五处监听，也不是因为他总是说他只想干几年。
he'd always said this in fact he didn't expect to win in 1974. But you know how he breaks the news to the Queen, Tom? No. They're washing up in a cottage. Oh, yes. On her estate. In Balmoral. Yeah, I think it's Balmoral.
他一直这么说，事实上他根本没料到能在1974年赢得大选。但你知道他是怎么把这个消息告诉女王的吗，汤姆？不知道。他们在巴尔莫勒尔堡的庄园里一间小屋里洗碗。哦，是的。在她的庄园里。在巴尔莫勒尔。对，我想是巴尔莫勒尔。
I can't remember. Yes. Or Sandringham, is it? No, Balmoral. They're washing up after tea or something or lunch. Because the Queen loved him, didn't she? The Queen got queen very well with wilson yeah and ever since people sort of said now why did harold resign why did because they've had all these plots to topple him in the late 60s he'd been incredibly unpopular in 1968 after the devaluation of the pound but here's the
我记不清了。是的。还是桑德灵厄姆？不，是巴尔莫勒尔。他们在喝完茶或午饭后洗碗。因为女王很喜欢他，不是吗？女王和威尔逊相处得非常好，是的，从那以后人们就一直在问：“哈罗德为什么要辞职？为什么……”因为在60年代末期经历过所有那些推翻他的阴谋之后，在1968年英镑贬值后他变得极其不受欢迎，但关键在于——
thing and this is i think the interesting thing why doesn't Wilson fall? Why doesn't somebody move against him? In his case, it's because he stacked his cabinet with what he called crown princes. So Roy Jenkins, James Callahan, Dennis Healy, Tony Benn, Anthony Crosland, all these kind of big figures. Because he knew they all hated each other so much that they would rather keep him on than give their rivals a chance to strike for the crown. I accept that. Would rather keep him on than give their rivals a chance to strike for the crown. And, you know, this is... I accept that. The problem for a prime minister is if they have a plausible rival, as Asghar did with Lloyd George, and successor. However...
我认为有趣的地方就在这里：为什么威尔逊没有倒台？为什么没有人对采取行动反对他？就他而言，那是因为他在内阁里安插了他所谓的“皇储”。所以罗伊·詹金斯、詹姆斯·卡拉汉、丹尼斯·希利、托尼·贝恩、安东尼·克罗斯兰，所有这些重量级人物。因为他知道他们互相痛恨得如此之深，以至于他们宁愿留住他，也不愿给自己的竞争对手夺取王冠的机会。我接受这一点。宁愿留住他，也不愿给竞争对手夺取王冠的机会。而且，你知道，这就是……对于一个首相来说，问题在于他是否有像阿斯奎斯对劳合·乔治那样的强劲对手和继任者。然而……
Wilson is a good way of escaping that trap. Yes, that's fine. But I still think that that is an illegitimate choice. You're outraged. You're outraged at this choice of Harold Wilson, aren't you? You should choose him for his resignation. i think the podcast should always surprise people yeah all right i think you know when we're not surprising our audience tom when i'm not surprising you well you have surprised me then then the spark will die i think that i well
威尔逊是摆脱这个困境的好方法。是的，这倒没问题。但我仍然认为这是一个不合规的选择。你很愤怒。你对哈罗德·威尔逊这个选择感到愤怒，对吧？你应该因为他的辞职而选择他。我认为播客总应该给人们带来惊喜。是的，好吧。当我们在没有给观众带来惊喜的时候，汤姆——当我没有给你带来惊喜时，火花就会熄灭。我认为我——
the spark will die if you continue to if you persist in illegitimate lists that break the rules. There must be rules, Dominic. So anyway, he resigned in 1976. And is that because he has Alzheimer's? No. I think he resigned because he'd always said he would do two years or so to his AIDS. People didn't believe him because they didn't believe a word Harold Wilson said. So he, in fact, had told some of his own cabinet.
如果你继续——如果你坚持那些打破规则的不合规名单，火花就会熄灭。必须有规则，多米尼克。所以不管怎样，他在1976年辞职了。这是因为他得了阿尔茨海默病吗？不。我认为他辞职是因为他一直对他的助手们说他只会干两年左右。人们不相信他，因为他们不相信哈罗德·威尔逊说的任何话。所以事实上，他甚至告诉了他自己内阁的一些成员。
He'd said, I'll probably go in about a year, I'll go in about six months or whatever. But people always said, oh, you can't believe a word Harold says. So when he did do it, they thought there must be something sinister behind it. And then he has a scandalous resignation honours list. The lavender list, either written or not written,
他说过：“我大概一年左右就会走，我大概六个月后就会走之类的话。”但人们总是说：“哦，你不能相信哈罗德说的任何话。”所以当他真的这么做时，他们认为这背后一定有什么不可告人的阴谋。然后他有了一份丑闻缠身的辞职封爵名单。那份“薰衣草名单”，根据你相信谁的不同，是由他的政治秘书玛西亚·威廉姆斯（福尔克兰德夫人）拟定的，还是没有拟定。
depending on whom you believe, by his political secretary, Marcia Williams, Lady Falklander. Lady Falklander, yeah. So that's quite, you see, I thought that's why you'd had it, because that's an entertaining resignation. Oh, it's a very entertaining resignation. By scandal and – And Wilson's a great example of somebody who resigns
福尔克兰德夫人，是的。所以这就很有意思了——你看，我以为这就是你选他的原因，因为这是一个充满娱乐性的辞职。哦，这是一个非常具有娱乐性的辞职。由于丑闻和——而且威尔逊是一个极好的例子：他辞职了，然后基本上就消失了。就像从未存在过一样。他去了锡利群岛，不是吗？是的，人们——穿着紧身短裤。不，他之前就已经在穿紧身短裤了。是吗？是的。
and then basically vanishes. Might as well never have existed. He goes off to the Silly Isles, doesn't he? Yeah, and people – Wears tight shorts. No, he was wearing the tight shorts before that. Was he? Yeah, he was.
非常强烈的造型。任何人都可以去谷歌搜索“哈罗德·威尔逊 紧身短裤”。他穿的那条短裤，嗯……他的造型非常抢眼。任何人只要谷歌一下“哈罗德·威尔逊 紧身短裤”，就会发现那种童子军的造型。好吧，威尔逊是童子军的超级粉丝，他痴迷于童子军活动，但不是——他不是对童子军本身入迷，那是错的，那是错的——他是对，是的，所以他在度假时打扮得像个童子军。好吧，我们真的扯得太远了。
Very strong look. Anyone wants to Google Harold Wilson, tight shorts. The shorts he uh yeah he was very strong look anyone wants to google harold wilson tight shorts the shorts the sort of boy scout look well wilson was a great fan of the scout he was obsessed by boys boy scouting but not he wasn't obsessed by boy scouts that's the wrong that's that's the wrong he was obsessed by yes but yeah so he dressed as a boy scout when he was on holiday right we've really spiraled off okay let's go to number eight uh because harold wilson's obviously everyone knows what the next one will be it's mrs thatcher yeah we've alluded to her in my brilliant introduction um i think that we should i mean people basically know the story of thatcher do that well i think we should tell it very very briefly tom because
好了，让我们进入第八位，因为哈罗德·威尔逊之后，显然每个人都知道下一个会是谁——那就是撒切尔夫人。是的，我们在我精彩的开场白中已经暗示过她了。我认为我们应该——我的意思是，人们基本上都知道撒切尔的故事。其实我们可以非常非常简短地讲述它，汤姆，因为
some of our listeners that would you believe are quite young the reason why i don't want to go into this too is because i want to do a whole episode on it not just i think we should do a week of episode right lots of opportunity so mrs thatcher is your in a way you can political time has become condensed so walpole's 20 years for mrs thatcher it's 11 years well or 10 years because by 1989 i think people are tired of her. They're tired of her abrasive style. There's a first leadership challenge, which everybody forgets, in December 1989 by Sir Anthony Mayer. And she won that by 314 to 33. And even then, Tom, I mean, this puts Boris's result into context.
我们的某些听众，你敢信，还相当年轻。我不想深入探讨这个的另一个原因是因为我想专门做一整集关于她的节目，不只是……我认为我们应该做一周的节目，有很多机会！所以撒切尔夫人是你的……在某种程度上，政治时间被浓缩了。沃波尔执政20年，而对于撒切尔夫人来说是11年，或者说10年，因为到1989年，我认为人们已经厌倦了她。他们厌倦了她那好斗的作风。在1989年12月，由安东尼·迈尔爵士发起了第一次党内领导权挑战，每个人都把这事忘了。她以314票对33票赢了。即便如此，汤姆——我的意思是，这把鲍里斯的结果衬托得很有对比度。
Even then, people said, oh, that's a very bad blow for the PM. 33 people voted against her so then jeffrey howe resigned her former chancellor i mean there's your point about chancellors and prime ministers in that relationship um he resigned he gave the resignation speech in the 13th of november 1990 you're an opening batsman and you find that your captain has broken your bat while you're in the pavilion. Yeah. Something like that.
即便如此，当时人们还是说：“哦，这对首相来说是一个沉重的打击。”有33人投了反对票。然后杰弗里·豪辞职了，她前任的财政大臣——我的意思是，这就印证了你刚才关于财政大臣和首相关系的观点——他辞职了，并在1990年11月13日发表了辞职演讲。你是一个开局 batsman（击球手），然后你发现你的队长在你待在休息室的时候把你的球棒给折断了。是的。类似的话。
Something that's worth that effect, anyway. Yeah. That was a very nice Geoffrey Howe, though. I enjoyed that a lot. Thank you. So Michael Heseltine challenged her. Again, she actually won that first ballot, 204 to 152. So she's in Paris, isn't she?
差不多就是那个意思，总之。是的。不过那是一次非常精彩的杰弗里·豪式的演讲。我很喜欢。谢谢你。所以迈克尔·赫塞尔廷向她发起了挑战。同样，她在第一轮投票中其实赢了，204票对152票。所以她当时在巴黎，对吧？
At Fontainebleau, yeah. And it's a kind of g7 no it's bigger than that it's a it's the summit to end the cold oh of course it is yes of course it is yes they're all there yes they're all there and she comes out and john sergeant who we've already mentioned as a strictly come dancing contender he's standing there wondering and she just kind of bustles up behind him doesn't we fight on we fight to win that's it i fight on i fight to win but of course she doesn't because she on we fight to win that's it i fight on i fight to win but of course she doesn't because she then goes back and the very next to london the very
在枫丹白露，是的。这是一个类似于G7的会议——不，比那个更大，这是一个旨在结束冷战的峰会。哦，当然，是的，当然是的，他们都在那儿，是的，他们都在那儿。她走出来，约翰·萨金特——我们之前提到过他曾是《严格来跳舞》的参赛选手——他就站在那里纳闷，而她就那样气势汹汹地从他身后走过来，不是吗？“我们继续战斗！我们为胜利而战！”就是这样。“我战斗到底，我为胜利而战。”但当然她没有，因为她
next evening all her cabinet kind of troop in to see her so all these sort of people ken clark william waldegrave uh john gummer chris patterne and john major her chancellor who has um a serendipitous bad, terrible teeth. Sorry, Tom, people can't see this, but I was pointing aggressively at my teeth. Yes, you were. You were. So John Major has a kind of diplomatic… He's got a wisdom tooth being straightened.
随后回到了伦敦，就在第二天晚上，她内阁的所有成员都排着队走进来看她——所以所有这些人：肯·克拉克、威廉·瓦尔德格雷夫、约翰·冈默、克里斯·帕滕，还有她的财政大臣约翰·米杰（约翰·梅杰）——他有一口……可以说是因祸得福的烂牙。抱歉，汤姆，人们看不见，但我刚才在充满攻击性地指着自己的牙齿。是的，你指了。你确实指了。所以约翰·梅杰有一种外交辞令般的……他有一颗正在矫正的智齿。
But that's not something you would fake, is it? I mean, you think it's like Prince Andrew's COVID, Tom? Possibly. That was the comparison that leapt in my mind as well. So basically, thatcher goes yeah even though she'd won that first ballot she's hold beneath the waterline so so we'll do her later but on this theme of of bad blood between prime ministers and um chancellors the next big beast to be brought down is of course sir tony blair yeah your friend tony so poor so tony
但这可不是你能假装出来的，对吧？我的意思是，你觉得这就像安德鲁王子得了新冠一样吗，汤姆？有可能。这也是我脑海中闪现的对比。所以基本上，撒切尔就这样下台了。是的，尽管她赢了第一轮投票，但她的水线以下已经漏水了——所以我们稍后会详细讲她。但顺着首相和财政大臣之间不和的主题，下一个被拉下马的大人物当然是托尼·布莱尔爵士。是的，你的朋友托尼。所以可怜的托尼……
he and he's probably sunk from 2005 i think so he's at the iraq war yeah but also i mean his majority which had previously been 167 was slashed to 66 it's not bad though is it i mean so i know my labor party standards three elections it's absolutely It's absolutely massive. Don't you think that the Thatcher thing, so you said that people are bored with her after 10 years, and obviously lots of people are fed up with her after about a week, but her own supporters are kind of fed up with her after 10 years. Well, the poll tax had alienated so many people. But I think there's a kind of unwritten rule that's come in
他可能从2005年开始就走下坡路了，我认为是这样。因为伊拉克战争。但同时，我的意思是，他原本167席的多数优势被大幅削减到了66席。这其实也不算太差，对吧？我的意思是，按照工党的标准，赢得三次大选，这绝对是……这绝对是个压倒性的优势。难道你不觉得撒切尔那件事——你刚才说人们在10年后对她感到厌烦，显然很多人甚至在大约一周后就对她厌烦透顶了，但她自己的支持者在10年后也对她有点厌烦了。嗯，人头税疏远了太多人。但我认为有一种不成文的规矩已经形成，
that 10 years is enough. I think people often say that. So obviously in America, there's an eight-year limit on the presidency. Or John Howard in Australia. Effectively, in British politics, there's a kind of 10-year limit. I think so. And Blair had reached that limit. I think political capital is a diminishing resource. And I think you spend it from the first day in office. It's very hard to replenish. Your majorities, by and large, gradually go down. But what I would also say about Blair is that he effortlessly remained prime minister for 10 years or whatever, however long it was.
那就是10年就够了。我认为人们经常这么说。所以在美国，总统有八年的任期限制。或者澳大利亚的约翰·霍华德。实际上，在英国政坛，有一种10年的隐形极限。我也这么认为。我认为政治资本是一种在不断消耗的资源。而且我认为你从上任的第一天起就在消耗它。这非常难补充。你的多数优势总体来说会逐渐减少。但我要对布莱尔说的是，他毫不费力地当了10年或无论多久的首相。
And then since then, for prime ministers, governing Britain, being prime minister of Britain has been like kind of riding a bucking bronco. I think that's true. But of course, he benefits from the fact the economy is incredibly rosy during his time in office. So the slings and arrows of outrageous fortune are very much sort of muffled, if a sling can be muffled, during Tony Blair's time in office. But it's still notable, Tom, that people turned... His people were happy. That people turned... God almighty.
从那以后，对于英国首相来说，治理英国、担任英国首相就像是骑在一头狂暴的公牛上。我认为这是真的。但当然，他受益于这样一个事实：在他任职期间，经济状况极其繁荣。所以在托尼·布莱尔任职期间，那些飞来的横祸和恶劣命运的箭矢在很大程度上都被压制了（如果箭矢也能被压制的话）。但仍然值得注意的是，汤姆，人们转向——他的人民是快乐的。人们转向——天哪。
His people were happy. What does Tony Blair got on you? That's what we want to know. I just think... You should team up with Alistair Campbell on our sister podcast. I just think that if you compare his premiership with what's followed, it's like the Antonine Age followed by the Age of Rust. The Age of Rust? the Age of Rust.
他的人民是快乐的。托尼·布莱尔到底抓住了你什么把柄？这才是我们想知道的。我只是觉得……你应该和阿拉斯泰尔·坎贝尔在我们姐妹播客里组个队。我只是觉得，如果你把他的首相任期跟后来的情况作对比，这就好比安东尼盛世之后紧接着就是黑暗的废铁时代。废铁时代？废铁时代。
The Age of Rust? The Age of Rust. Well, anyway, listen, we should do How He Fell before you. I mean, you're just getting tearful now. Yes. I'll have to stage an intervention like that woman at the dinner party about the Neville Chamberlain speech. So what brings him down, funnily enough, is, and this is, again, much forgotten. In the summer of 2006, Israel went to war against Hezbollah. So what brings him down, funnily enough, is, and this is, again, much forgotten.
废铁时代？废铁时代。好吧，不管怎样，听着，我们应该在你……讲讲他是怎么下台的。我的意思是，你现在都快感动得流泪了。是的。我得像晚宴上那个因为内维尔·张伯伦演讲而发飙的妇女一样，去介入干预一下。那么，有趣的是，是什么打倒了他呢？这也是很大程度上被遗忘了的一点。在2006年夏天，以色列对真主党发动了战争，
In the summer of 2006, Israel went to war against Hezbollah and attacked Lebanon. And there was huge outrage within the Labour Party about this. Blair refused to condemn Israel. He said, you know. Be the wrong thing to do. Exactly. He said it was, you know, it was a complicated issue, blah, blah, blah, blah. And on the 5th of September, 17 Labour Party MPs, including junior defence minister and future Corbyn deputy Tom Watson and seven parliamentary private secretaries,
并袭击了黎巴嫩。工党内部对此产生了巨大的愤怒。布莱尔拒绝谴责以色列。他说，你知道的……那样做是不对的。没错。他说，这是一个复杂的问题，巴拉巴拉巴拉。然后在9月5日，17名工党议员——包括初级国防大臣、未来的科尔宾副手汤姆·沃森以及七名议会私人秘书——
they signed this letter saying he's got to go. You know, he needs to, because Blair has already basically signed his own political death warrant by saying he won't fight another election. And this letter, I mean, it's only 17 MPs. And actually you're answering on eight points. I mean, 17 MPs by today's standards, I mean, you know, that's nothing.
他们签署了一封信，称他必须下台。你知道的，他需要离开，因为布莱尔实际上已经通过宣布不再参加下一次大选，签署了自己的政治死刑令。而这封信——我的意思是，只有17名议员。其实你在回答八个要点。我的意思是，按照今天的标准，17名议员，我的意思是，这算什么。
But at the time it seems like this sort of great- It's like the murder of Commodus. Is it the murder of Commodus? Pretty much. Yeah. Okay. I'm just spinning this. Yeah.
但在当时，这感觉像是一场伟大的——这就像刺杀康茂德一样。是刺杀康茂德吗？差不多。是的。好吧。我只是随口胡编的。是的。
What's that? What's the murder? So the murder of Commodus seems an outrageous event at the time, but later on just seemed perfectly normal. Yeah, absolutely. Now everyone's getting murdered in the crisis of the third century. Yes. All right.
什么？什么刺杀？所以刺杀康茂德在当时看起来是一件极其出格的大事，但后来看起来就完全正常了。是的，绝对的。现在三世纪危机里人人都在被谋杀。好吧。但是那个“格兰尼塔公约”事件呢？整件事？因为本质上布莱尔和布朗是铁杆盟友。你答应过我的，托尼。是的。对戈登·布朗的模仿真是绝妙。难道这不是一个因素吗？我想大概是的。
But what about the Granita thing? The whole thing? Because essentially Blair and Brown are the big allies. You promised me, Tony. Yeah. That's a brilliant impersonation of Gordon Brown. Is that not a factor? I think probably.
但是格兰尼塔宫的事呢？整件事？因为本质上布莱尔和布朗是紧密的盟友。你答应过我，托尼。是的。这是对戈登·布朗的精彩模仿。这难道不是一个因素吗？我想可能是吧。
Brown's kind of seething resentment. Yeah, of course. And feeling that he's owed Downing Street and that Blair's not sticking by his word. Blairites would say he could have lanced that boil by just sacking Gordon Brown sometime in his second term, probably, or moving him or in some way just getting rid of him and that Gordon Brown wouldn't have had the strength to launch it. But that is the kind of the classic example of a prime minister and chancellor locked in a kind of death grip. But Tony Blair, probably, it's hard to imagine a scenario in which any prime minister would get more than 10 years 10 years is a pretty good run I think he is brought down by his own MPs but I mean he was going to go within a couple of years anyway it's hard to believe that Tony
布朗那种暗自压抑的怨恨。是的，当然。还有觉得唐宁街本来就该是他的，而布莱尔没有信守承诺。布莱尔派会说，他本可以在第二任期内随时通过解雇戈登·布朗，或者调动他，或者用某种方式摆脱他，来把这个脓包挑破，而且可能戈登·布朗当时也没有实力发起反抗。但这就是首相和财政大臣陷入某种死局的经典例子。不过托尼·布莱尔，可能很难想象会有哪个首相能任职超过10年，10年已经是很长的一段任期了，我认为他是被自己的议员拉下马的，但我的意思是，反正他过几年也要走了，很难相信托尼
Blair would have fought the 2010 election and won it do you not think I think he did I think he did I don't think he would I think I think I think he was i mean i think his effect on the electorate was like the sirens on odysseus no i think you think that until they lose i mean somebody said on when we advertised that we were doing this this evening just before we did it somebody on on twitter said would margaret thatcher have won the 1992 election everyone hated her she was abrasive i think a lot of people were sick of tony blair i think they became sick in due course i think i think that kind of the weird thing about blair was the people was kind of the delayed shock of the iraq war i mean he still won the election after the iraq war it did but but but but tom in 2005 labor lost i think 101 seats had they continued to lose at the
布莱尔会参加2010年的大选并赢得胜利，难道你不这么认为吗？我认为他会，我认为他会，我不认为他会，我觉得，我觉得，我的意思是，我对他在选民中的影响力的看法就像奥德修斯的塞壬海妖一样不，我不认为你会这么觉得，直到他们输掉。我的意思是，当我们宣传我们今晚要做这个节目的时候，就在开始之前，推特上有人说玛格丽特·撒切尔会赢得1992年的大选吗？每个人都讨厌她，她很刻薄，我想很多人都对托尼·布莱尔感到厌烦了，我想他们最终还是厌烦了。我觉得，我觉得关于布莱尔最奇怪的事情是人们对伊拉克战争的延迟震惊，我的意思是他在伊拉克战争后仍然赢得了大选，确实如此，但是，但是，汤姆，在2005年工党失去了，我想是101个议席，如果他们继续以
same rate after a recession at the end of the decade? I don't think so. I don't think so. Because I think, I mean, Cameron didn't beat Brown. He didn't decisively beat Brown. He had to have a coalition. And Brown was, although he did great things with the aftermath of the crash, I mean, he was not a popular prime minister. And he perhaps wasn't temperamentally suited to the job. So Blair wasn't peter mandelson this i just think blair was very temp i think blair actually a bit like cameron was temperamentally suited to being a prime minister people quite like the idea of him as a prime minister he was kind of you know he he behaved and looked like people imagine a prime minister should look like yeah i think that's quite an important anyway i think it's very important
同样的速率在十年末的经济衰退后失去议席呢？我不这么认为。我不这么认为。因为我认为，我的意思是，卡梅伦并没有击败布朗。他并没有决定性地击败布朗。他不得不组建联合政府。而且布朗，尽管他在应对金融危机余波方面做了很多出色的工作，我的意思是，他并不是一个受欢迎的首相。他可能在性格上也不太适合这份工作。所以布莱尔并不是皮特·曼德尔森，我只是觉得布莱尔在性格上——我觉得布莱尔实际上有点像卡梅伦，在性格上很适合当首相，人们相当喜欢他作为首相的形象，他给人的感觉，你知道，他的行为和外表就像人们想象中首相应该有的样子，是的，我觉得这相当重要，不管怎样，我认为这非常重要
we're spying off into a different theme playing the part of being a prime minister should look like yeah i think that's quite an important anyway i think it's very important we're spying off into a different theme playing the part of being a prime minister yes is massively important i completely and in that sense blair is a bit kind of disraeli's you know he's he's a showman he's he's an actor he plays the part he's he knows how to tickle the tummy as i have to as i have told the readers of the daily mail many times he's a mountebank no he's he's he's an upstanding mountebank well anyway so that's so that's Blair games a contradiction in terms and our final one our final one number 10 is Theresa May yes so the interesting thing about Theresa May is how long she survives because she has that weird period right at the beginning when she has this incredible honeymoon everyone loves her don't
我们偏离到了另一个主题，扮演一个首相应该有的样子，是的，我觉得这相当重要，不管怎样，我认为这非常重要，我们偏离到了另一个主题，扮演一个首相的角色，是的，这是极其重要的，我完全同意。从这个意义上说，布莱尔有点像迪斯雷利，你知道，他是一个表演者，他是一个演员，他扮演这个角色，他知道如何讨好大家，正如我多次对《每日邮报》的读者所说的那样，他是一个江湖骗子。不，他是一个正直的江湖骗子。好吧，不管怎样，这就是布莱尔，自相矛盾的集合体。我们的最后一位，最后一位，第10位是特雷莎·梅，是的，所以关于特雷莎·梅，有趣的是她撑了多久，因为她在刚上台时经历了一段奇怪的时期，当时她有着令人难以置信的蜜月期，每个人都爱她，不是吗？
they her approval rating she doesn't say anything she never comes out of her office everybody thinks that she said everybody that's all she ever says it means brexit so everybody said well that's i find that very powerful and persuasive um and then she held the election and said that she liked running through fields of wheat and everybody turned against her so she also she said nothing has changed when everything has changed. Everything has changed, yeah. So that's the 8th of June, 2017. She lost her majority.
她的支持率居高不下，她什么都不说，她从不离开她的办公室，每个人都认为她说过每个人这就是她所说的一切，这意味着脱欧，所以每个人都说，好吧，我发现这非常有力量且具有说服力，然后她举行了大选，说她喜欢在麦田中奔跑，结果所有人都反对她，于是她说，没有什么改变，当一切都变了。一切都变了，是的。所以那是2017年6月8日。她失去了多数席位。
I mean, that night when the result came through, people were speculating, you know, will she be gone in days, in weeks? And the extraordinary thing is she survives for almost two years. So she goes all the way through to December 2018. And then she has a confidence vote because the sort of the Tory ultras of the, you know, the successors, I suppose you could say, in some ways to the ultras who had done for Robert Peel. They force a confidence vote in December 2018, which she wins by 200 votes to 117. And of course, the tremendous irony is that at the time, the Jacob Rees-Mogg and co are queuing up to say,
我的意思是，当晚结果出来的时候，人们都在猜测，你知道，她会在几天内、几周内下台吗？而令人难以置信的是，她竟然支撑了将近两年。所以她一直坚持到了2018年12月。然后她遭遇了一场不信任投票，因为那些保守党极右翼分子，你知道的，某种程度上可以说是当年搞垮罗伯特·皮尔的极右翼分子的继承者。他们在2018年12月强行发起了一场不信任投票，她以200票对117票赢了。当然，最大的讽刺是，当时雅各布·里斯-莫格之流正排着队说
well, so she has to go. Yeah, absolutely. And I mean, that's the extraordinary thing, the shamelessness of it. And now Rees-Mogg says he was mistaken. One is enough. One is enough. Yes.
好吧，所以她必须走。是的，绝对的。我的意思是，这就是不可思议的地方，太无耻了。而现在里斯-莫格却说他弄错了。有一个就够了。有一个就够了。是的。
Yeah, so I've just got it here. So when that result came through against theresa may this is a very bad result for the prime minister 170 votes against her much worse than she thought and says that she should resign because the overwhelming majority of backbenchers have voted against her and now he's saying uh one's enough yeah i'll do that's fine i think i think what you're fussing about? I think Jacob Rees-Mogg knows very well that basically there's only one conceivable person who would ever have him as a minister. And that one happens to be the prime minister.
是的，我刚好把它拿在手里。所以当针对特雷莎·梅的那个结果出来时，这对首相来说是一个非常糟糕的结果，有170票反对她，比她想象的要糟糕得多，并说她应该辞职，因为绝大多数后排议员都投了反对她的票，而现在他说，呃，有一个就够了，是的，我这就做，没关系，我想，我想你在大惊小怪什么？我想雅各布·里斯-莫格心里很清楚，基本上只有一个可能的人会让她当部长。而那个人恰好就是首相。
So she also won a confidence vote in the House of Commons. So that was January 2019. She won by 325 to 306. And I think anyone who remembers this period, well, we all remember it. I mean, this appeared to be a period in which teresa may was facing confidence votes every three days of various kinds it was either confidence votes on but they call it brexit meaningful meaningful yeah just awful i just blanked the whole i just uh there were endless votes on i mean for our
所以她还在下议院赢得了一场不信任投票。那是2019年1月。她以325票对306票获胜。我想任何经历过这段时期的人，好吧，我们都记得。我的意思是，这段时期似乎特雷莎·梅每隔三天就要面临各种各样的不信任投票，要么是对什么的信任投票，但他们称之为有意义的脱欧，有意义的，是的，简直太糟糕了，我简直把整个事情都从脑子里抹去了，我只是，有无数关于，我的意思是，对我们的
overseas listeners there were just endless votes on abstruse and incredibly impenetrable Brexit arrangements, which all were defeated in various combinations. Kind of angry people from Ulster shouting at her. Just terrible. But yes, so early 2019, she has all these votes. But she lingers on till May 2019. And I think the lesson of that, I mean, there were two lessons. I think one is, as I said, political capital is a diminishing resource. I think when it's gone, you almost never, ever get it back.
海外听众来说，有无数关于晦涩难懂且极其令人费解的脱欧安排的投票，所有这些安排都在各种组合下被否决了。来自阿尔斯特的愤怒人群对她大喊大叫。简直太糟糕了。但是是的，所以在2019年初，她进行了所有这些投票。但她一直拖延到2019年5月。我想这其中的教训，我的意思是，有两个教训。我认为一是，正如我所说，政治资本是一种不断减少的资源。我认为当它用尽时，你几乎永远、永远也无法将它赢回来。
It's hard to think of. I would say actually Wilson is the only example I can really think of, modern example of somebody who appeared to lose all his political capital in the late 1960s but then managed to to well he becomes he's in he's in office but not in power would you say yes he's very buffeted by his i mean he's not he's not a jenkins callahan he's he's he's well he spends an enormous amount of time basically playing political chess with his own cabinet yeah um and wilson's a great survivor he's very wily
很难想出一个例子。其实我想说威尔逊是我能真正想到的唯一一个例子，一个现代的例子，他在20世纪60年代末似乎失去了所有的政治资本，但随后设法——好吧，他身居高位却没有实权，你会这么说吗？是的，他饱受他的人的冲击，我的意思是，他不是詹金斯，也不是卡拉汉，他，他，他，好吧，他花了大量时间基本上和自己的内阁玩政治国际象棋，是的，呃，威尔逊是个极其顽强的人，他非常精明
uh he's also a likable i think that matters because i think people ultimately don't want to move against him because they he's a nice he's a nice person as i always say of harold wilson he's the prime minister you'd want as your next door neighbor to borrow a hose or some such yeah but um washing up like the queen but yes exactly but so political capital diminishes but the other lesson i think is that from theresa may or indeed from tony blair actually is that you can be a long time dying so even though the game appears to be up so it's quite hard gordon brown would definitely agree with us it's quite hard to get someone out of number 10 if they don't want to go so uh we're doing this
呃，他也很讨人喜欢，我认为这很重要，因为我认为人们最终不想对付他，因为他，他是个好人，正如我常说的哈罗德·威尔逊，他是你想请来当隔壁邻居借根水管或诸如此类东西的首相，是的，但是，洗盘子就像女王一样，但确实如此，完全正确。所以政治资本在减少，但我认为另一个教训来自特雷莎·梅，或者实际上来自托尼·布莱尔，那就是你可以死很久，所以即使大势已去——所以这很难，戈登·布朗肯定会同意我们的看法——要想把某人赶出唐宁街10号，如果他们不想走的话，是相当困难的，所以，我们正在这样做
you know off off the back of the uh the no confidence result against johnson which he's won and we talked about neville chamberlain being an honorable man who yes does the decent thing um i mean boris would never do that i mean his mean, the whole point of his premiership is to be in power. And in fact, for a while now, it seemed like the main purpose of the current government is basically to keep Johnson in power. Now, he's famously on record, Tom, of saying his favourite film is The Godfather Part II. I thought it was Jaws.
你知道，是在约翰逊不信任投票结果出炉的背景下进行的，他赢了那场投票，我们谈到了内维尔·张伯伦是一个正派的人，他会做出体面的举动，我的意思是鲍里斯永远不会那样做，我的意思是，他担任首相的全部意义就是为了掌权。事实上，有一段时间，现政府的主要目的似乎基本上就是让约翰逊继续掌权。现在，众所周知，汤姆，他曾公开表示他最喜欢的电影是《教父第二集》。我以为是《大白鲨》。
I think he's – how unlike him to have given different answers. But, you know, he obviously has this sort of sense of himself as this sort of Michael Corleone figure who will sacrifice. Well, the big dog. Save big dog, isn't it? Boris's backers have been running this operation. He's the big dog. Yes, and his opponents wanted to have Operation rinker to um to get rid of him so rinker for those of you don't know if you should listen to our jeremy thorpe podcast rinker was a
我想他是——他给出不同的答案是多么符合他的风格啊。但是，你知道，他显然觉得自己就像迈克尔·科尔里昂一样的人物，会作出牺牲。嗯，大狗。拯救大狗，对吧？鲍里斯的支持者一直在策划这件事。他是大狗。是的，他的对手想要发起“林克行动”来摆脱他，所以“林克行动”，对于那些不知道的人来说——如果你听过我们的杰里米·索普播客，“林克行动”是一个
dog cruelly murdered um on the orders of the leader of the liberal party um well kind of it's a great it's a great episode if you haven't listened to it do go and get it yes okay so do you think that uh i mean i, the whole basis of this episode is that he's now finished, but maybe he isn't. Maybe he'll snagger on. Maybe he'll win the election. as everybody knows who's ever read my columns but um i think 148 of your own mps against you i think that's that's ultimately terminal maybe not immediately but i think it's very hard to go into a general election saying you know so so the thatcher lost the that thatcher won a vote of confidence and resigned almost immediately you Well, she won a leadership election. May won a vote of confidence, staggered on for, what, six months, I think, and then resigned. Yes.
残忍谋杀的狗，是在自由党领袖的命令下……好吧，这算是一集精彩的节目，如果你还没听过，快去听听吧。好的，所以你觉得，我的意思是，这一集的整个基础就是他现在完蛋了，但也许他并没有。也许他会勉强撑下去。也许他会赢得大选。正如所有读过我的专栏的人都知道的那样，但是，我想有148名你自己的议员反对你，我认为这最终是致命的，也许不会立刻见效，但我认为很难在参加大选时说，你知道，所以——撒切尔输了，撒切尔赢得了一场信任投票，并几乎立刻辞职了。好吧，她赢得了一场党内领导层选举。梅赢得了一场信任投票，勉强撑了大概六个月，然后辞职了。是的。
John Major won a vote of confidence, staggered on, fought the election, and got absolutely murdered in the next election. So I would reckon that if Johnson johnson doesn't resign then he will lead the conservatives to a massive defeat yeah and the my prognostication but who you know as you say who knows to pick up on your john major point tom we didn't mention john major at all but in july 1995 john major faced a leadership challenge from john redwood uh put up or shut up yes people may remember that tremendous press conference that john redwood gave where he was surrounded by people who i think can fairly be described as the more colorful end of the conservative party stressed in blazers terrible places anyway um major one by a pretty big majority. It was 218 votes.
约翰·梅杰赢得了一场信任投票，勉强撑下去，参加了大选，并在接下来的大选中被彻底击败。所以我估计，如果约翰逊不辞职，那么他将带领保守党走向惨败，是的，这是我的预测，但是谁知道呢，正如你所说，谁知道呢？顺便提一下你的约翰·梅杰观点，汤姆，我们根本没有提到约翰·梅杰，但在1995年7月，约翰·梅杰面临来自约翰·雷德wood的领导权挑战——要么闭嘴，要么拿出行动，是的，人们可能还记得约翰·雷德wood召开的那场轰动的记者招待会，他被我认为可以公正地描述为保守党内更具色彩的一端的人包围着，穿着西装夹克，可怕的夹克，不管怎样——梅杰以相当大的多数票获胜。那是218票。
And John Redwood, his challenger, won 89. So a pretty sizable margin. Major's private target, Tom, was 215. So he only beat it by three. And he decided he would resign if he didn't get 215. But again, Major is, I think it's fair to say, a man with, I mean, not a perfect man, but a man with perhaps a little more integrity than Boris Johnson. And I say that as I'm not a sort of great Boris hater, but I think it would be very hard for anybody to claim that he was a man, a paragon of virtue.
而他的挑战者约翰·雷德wood获得了89票。所以差距相当大。汤姆，梅杰的私下目标是215票。所以他仅仅比目标多赢了三票。他曾决定如果没有得到215票就辞职。但同样，梅杰，我认为可以公平地说，是一个有——虽然不是完美的人，但可能比鲍里斯·约翰逊更有正直感的人。我说这话并不是因为我是某种极度厌恶鲍里斯的人，但我认为很难有人宣称他是一个品德高尚的典范。
Well, yeah. And the Corleone comparison. Yeah. He would have to be dragged dragged out in a coffin basically i mean they've got two by-elections coming uh which i think they'll probably both they'll lose both of them and they're important aren't they because they're one's a red wall one is kind of tory heartlands exactly and i think you know especially one of the things that did for margaret thatcher was the economy turning
好吧，是的。还有科尔里昂的比较。是的。基本上得用棺材把他拖出去，我的意思是他们即将迎来两次补选——我想他们可能会两次都输掉，而且它们很重要，不是吗？因为一个是红墙选区，一个是保守党腹地，完全是这样，而且我认为，你知道，特别是导致玛格丽特·撒切尔下台的原因之一就是经济背叛了
against her. She lost control of inflation. Interest rates went up. Sort of Tory homeowners feeling the pinch with inflation going up and likely to go higher. But by the end of the year, it's very hard to see how things will get easier for Boris Johnson. And, you know, he will make if I was if I was a Tory party MP, I would think about it this way. He's going to become a very convenient scapegoat a year from now. You dump him, then you get a new leader and you go in saying, well,
她。她失去了对通货膨胀的控制。利率上升了。保守党的房主们感受到了通货膨胀上升带来的压力，而且可能还会更高。但到今年年底，很难看出事情会如何对鲍里斯·约翰逊变得容易。而且，你知道，他会——如果我是保守党议员，我会这样想：一年后他将成为一个非常方便的替罪羊。你甩掉他，然后你选出一个新领袖，去竞选时说，好吧，
we've turned the page, you know, we've, we've learned the lessons, all that sort of thing. So I think we could easily be doing this podcast again. At half past 10. Well, we could put that same podcast yeah with the same disagreement yeah we just change it tweak it a bit at the beginning so okay that's a terrible insight into your i hope the listeners aren't too shocked by that but that's the kind of um beady-eyed wheeler dealing that really stay ahead in politics isn't it that's what david
我们已经翻开了新的一页，你知道，我们已经吸取了教训，诸如此类的事情。所以我想我们很可能会在10点半再次录制这个播客。好吧，我们可以用同一个播客，带着同样的异议，只需在开头稍微修改调整一下。好吧，这对你的心眼来说是个可怕的洞察，我希望听客们不会对此感到太震惊，但这就是那种斤斤计较、勾心斗角的手段，才能真正在政治中保持领先，不是吗？这就是大卫·劳埃德·乔治会做的事，
lord george would have done it is that's the david lord george option right i think we've done enough um and our poor producers have to go off and lick this into shape yeah tom so we should probably tom's gonna go and catch up with love island yeah i am yeah and i think we should do the uh the love island episode but we can discuss this we definitely should do it it. We're so going to do it. And all the extra listeners we would have attracted because of our talk of the Earl of Wilmington. I think they'll stay for Love Island. So, yes, win-win. Okay.
那是大卫·劳埃德·乔治的选择，对吧？我想我们已经说得够多了，我们可怜的制作人们得去把这集节目剪辑成形了。是的，汤姆，我们大概应该——汤姆要去赶着看《爱情岛》了，是的，我是，是的，我想我们应该做《爱情岛》那一期的播客，我们可以讨论这个，我们绝对应该做。我们肯定会做的。所有因为我们谈论威尔明顿伯爵而吸引来的额外听众，我想他们会留下来看《爱情岛》的。所以，这是一个双赢的局面。好吧。
All right. Well, thank you for joining this. All very spontaneous. All very exciting. I hope you've enjoyed it. And we will be back on Thursday, won't we, with Denunzio, the first fascist. The first fascist. We'll see you then.
好的，谢谢大家参与。非常即兴，非常精彩。希望你们喜欢。我们周四会回来，对吧？讲讲第一位法西斯分子邓宁赞寿。第一位法西斯分子。到时候见。
Bye-bye. Bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我们主持了《娱乐的余烬》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、八卦猛料，在问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目以及提前购买现场门票的权益，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何一句话即可留下评论。